[Music]
foreign
did you find her voting station
yeah there's only the four voting places
even four seats and she was looking for
the one in front of them side
[Music]
foreign
personally
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
at the house adjourned from the session
of April 21st 2022. are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned house will attend
to a Prayer by house chaplain represent
Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of Saint
Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
thank you Mr Speaker
let us be in a spirit of Prayer
o Spirit of the Living God fall afresh
on us
guide and direct us this day
May our conversations today be
conversations that reflect your spirit
oh God
a spirit of respect for each other
a respect that our word spoke and
reflect who we are as well as whose we
are
o Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on us
may we represent those that elected us
to the best of our ability and may we
through that representation reflect your
light out into our communities and out
into the world
May others see that Harmony and peace
can exist even when we don't agree
no Spirit of the Living God
melt us and mold us
shape us o God to be the people you want
us to be
and that we are molded and shaped by
your love
you are a god of love
and let us reflect that love to everyone
we meet
o Spirit of the Living God
fill us and use us
fill us with your love and peace so that
we lead in the same way
use us to be your clear image here in
New Hampshire
and it is our hope that image will
project outside of this chamber and out
into the world that you have created and
entrusted to our care
the spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on us
God bless those who lead us today
keep your guiding hand on each one we
pray
o Spirit of the Living God
fall afresh on the world
be with the people of Ukraine and with
Russia
be in other parts of the world where
there is turmoil and anguish
we pray your Shalom and love will be
victorious
recognizes the member from Lebanon
representative George Sykes will lead us
[Music]
the chair now recognizes Hannah Grove an
18 year old student from miscoma Valley
Regional High School who will sing on
oh say can you see
by the dawn's early
light
what so proudly we held
at the twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
[Music]
by
all the
ramparts we watched were so
gallantly streamed
[Music]
wreck of the bombs bursting in foreign I
gave proof through the night that our
flag was still there
oh say does that Star Spangled
or the last
of the free
and the home of the bridge faith
[Applause]
house will attend to requests for leaves
of absence
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Eamonn Birch boros
Cleaver Ellis Freitas gay gourd Kelsey
Kimball Lawton major McBride pimonte
Varney Vincent white the day important
business Representatives Aldrich
Belanger
board is Amanda Bolden Conley Cornell
Cody dutzy Herbert Langley Lundgren
Macbeth James Murphy Richards Suzanne
Smith Timothy Smith snow Thompson
trottier the day illness in the family
representative Denise Smith
the day death in the family
these leaves of absence shall be grand
and I personally would like to
recognize in
congratulate our colleague Gary Hopper
for being back in the chamber for for
[Applause]
the house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome April gov and Linda Landry
mother and grandmother of the singer
guests of Representative Sykes Alicia
Greg guest of Representative tularsky
Angela and Matthew Brown guests of
Representative rung Lorraine lindenberg
guest of Representative prudhome O'Brien
Angela Brennan guest of Representative
walls they are with us in the gallery
today
[Applause]
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
Judiciary Senate Bill 399 removed by
representative Marjorie Smith
from the committee on science technology
and energy Senate Bill 429 removed by
representative oxenham
from the committee on Ways and Means
Senate Bill 316 removed by
representative abrami
are there any other bills to be removed
Zen of Osmond moves at the consent
calendar with the relevant amendments
are in print as printed in a day's house
record be adopted
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
house will attend the bills on the Regal
calendar
okay
majority of the committee on children
and family law to which those referred
Senate Bill 114 FN act relative to child
care scholarships having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is in expedient
to legislate
percent of Jody Nelson for the majority
minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass from Pat long for the majority
minority of the committee
thank you Mr Speaker
Senate 144 is a three-month Child Care
pilot plan shifting from attendance base
to enrollment-based reimbursement for
participating child care providers
Financial appropriation have already
been appropriated through the child care
and Development Fund followed by the
American Rescue plan
the Hampshire families are currently at
a critical stage in locating affordable
child care services all too often
parents are left with remaining out of
the workforce due to the lack of
available and affordable child care
providers this has been leaving New
Hampshire's economy struggling with
finding workers
majority's concern of providers possibly
receiving payment when a child is absent
as a potential concern for the minority
also however the bill charges that the
report addressed that possibility
the report is due on or before September
1st 2022 which will give us both the
actual absentee rate and leaves time to
file an LSR in the next term with real
absentee numbers and other critical data
and assuring a solution that works for
New Hampshire's economy and families
chair recognizes representative Jody
Nelson
Mr Speaker I rise in support of the
majority recommendation of inexpedient
to legislate this bill establishes the
child care scholarship pilot program to
provide enrollment-based reimbursement
to child care providers as opposed to
attendance-based reimbursement to child
care providers who accept Child Care
scholarships through the child care and
Development Fund although the committee
can agree that finding solutions to the
state's Child Care problem is important
the majority of the committee finds that
there are areas of this particular bills
tax that are of concern one such area of
concern is that the billing is set up so
that it should continue unless a child
exceeds two weeks of consecutive
absences from the program without
notification to the provider regarding
circumstances and agreed upon return
date this framework could allow for a
child to be absent several times a week
and still be enrolled in the program
causing unnecessary costs to the program
and possibly preventing space for
another child who is in need of care
because of our concerns with this bill I
respectfully ask you to press the green
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexp meeting to
legislative Senate Bill 144 are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted Senator Berry declared
a conflict of interest and did not
participate
majority of committee on children and
family law to which was referred Senate
Bill 326 FN
enact relative to developing a plan to
create the office of Early Childhood
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate percent of Josh Ocala for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
report the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass it's enough Patrick long
for the minority of the committee chair
thank you Mr Speaker
Senegal 326 establishes an office of
Early Childhood charged with
coordinating consolidating and
integrating Early Childhood programs
currently the system is designed with a
variety of state agencies councils
commissions and task forces charge with
working towards solutions that our
family need and support for their child
the system is confusing complicated and
difficult to access creating a single
office of Early Childhood will Empower
our families with a One-Stop shop for
the care and support of our families are
looking for
on January 23 2020 the governor issued
an executive order creating the council
for thriving children directing the
Department of Health and Human Services
in the Department of Education in
seeking to establish a joint office of
Early Childhood care and education that
further enable coordination into local
communities
we hear a testimony from several members
of that Council supporting this position
the purpose of this bill Builds on the
vision builds onto governance work
already happening
I'm of the opinion that current system
leaves gaps that are devastating to New
Hampshire families and children this
office will fill those gaps and minimize
if not eliminate these disadvantages
nothing is more important than early
childhood development such an important
time for the child should not end up in
a bureaucratic mess this office will
allow for greater coordination between
departments and programs and will
strengthen support and services
available to families thank you Mr
Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in the support of
the itl motion to for SB 326 because the
governor already put in uh
an executive order which tasked uh
board to come up with a plan to make
this uh this
children uh
uh
this uh what was this called uh the
office of of the the uh
early childhood and now they're asking
for a bill to do the exact same thing
and so this this board already has money
and they can already make this uh plan
for the office of of early childhood and
so this bill is not necessary and I hope
the motion before us is the majority
commit a report of inexpecting to
legislate and Senate Bill 326. a
division has been called members take
foreign
call has been requested by
representative Osborne is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
make sure everybody turn has turned on
foreign
house will be in order
in expedient to legislate on Senate bill
326.
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that every
initiative focused on Early Childhood
will always bring a return on investment
benefiting Granite State families
and if I know that early childhood is a
bar bipartisan issue
and SB 326 creates a plan with no fiscal
note that helps execute the governor's
executive order directing DHHS and the
doe to establish an office of Early
Childhood care and education
and if I believe that investing in our
children is always good for New
Hampshire
would I now vote no and press the red
button to defeat the itl so another
chair recognizes representative D Simone
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
listening
if I know
that the governor appointed a multitude
of us to the council for thriving
children
and if I know that in doing that his
Express purpose was for us to do what
host uh what Senate Bill 326 is asking
us to do
that this bill will only create another
governmental bureaucracy
that would create such redundancy that's
not necessary then I would vote using
motion before us is a majority committee
report have been explained to legislate
on Senate Bill 326 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
foreign
members present had an opportunity to
vote
178 voting a 151 voting a committee
committee on children the family law to
which those referred Senate Bill 431 FN
and act relative to child support in
cases with equal or approximately equal
parenting schedules having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment representative Joshua Keller
for the committee
the amendment is one five seven five
eight printed in house record 17 Page
96.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye as opposed
nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
chair recognizes
representative altrueller for to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
good morning
in the very best of circumstances
parenting children is unique challenging
rewarding time consuming and expensive
it is life altering and the kids
well they didn't have any choice about
much of anything in this so in theory we
all do the best we can with what we've
got
co-parenting Under One Roof is tough
because parenting is tough not all
families live under the same roof though
and some of those families live under
separate roofs because they have extreme
conflict that makes parenting under the
same roof unsafe
when parents don't live together and
share parenting duties the state of New
Hampshire believes the guiding principle
in that Arrangement should be what is in
the best interest of the child in SB 431
we are concerned with the parenting
issue of Child Support which is designed
to maintain a child's living standard
and ensure that their needs are covered
Senate Bill 431 does state
quote equal or approximately equal
parenting residential responsibilities
in and of itself shall not eliminate the
need for child support and shall not by
itself constitute grounds for adjustment
which translated means if a child lives
50 percent of the time with one parent
and fifty percent of the time with
another parent it does not mean that
child support is not in order child
support sometimes may very well be in
order
also if a custody agreement changes from
a 70 30 split or a 60 40 split to 50 of
the time with one parent and 50 percent
of the time with the other parent that
change doesn't automatically trigger an
elimination of Child Support
so when we establish that some children
spend equal amounts of time under two
different roofs
how do we ensure that those places are
not so unequal that the children aren't
living in the lap of luxury in one home
living in poverty in the other
how do we ensure that children in both
homes have shelter clothing educational
supplies
daycare after school programs or
extracurricular activities
how do we determine who pays for health
insurance
co-payments if a child gets sick at one
parent's home versus the other
what about when they're old enough to
drive who pays for drivers education or
car insurance
the answers to those questions are in
our child support formulas but how do we
come up with the formula based on but
how did we come up with this formula and
as is required in our current statute
the Department of Health and Human
Services Bureau of Child Support is
conducting a review of all of our policy
guidelines and the report will be re
completed and released to us
at at the end of December of 2022.
the child and family law committee heard
from mediators who work with these
parents and pointed out that the
guidelines are not clear and this has
led to a lot of litigation
what we heard that a fair way to
determine what is in the best interest
of New Hampshire's children is to have a
net the difference calculation
when the higher earning parent earns
less
then 60 of the total parental net income
the difference between the two is the
determining factor in calculating child
support this formula added to the
guidelines would achieve a reasonably
similar lifestyle in each home
but
the amendment that just passed for
Senate Bill 431 instead
complicates an already complicated
process even further by adding in a
requirement of a 120 percent multiplier
be added to the formula before getting
to the net the difference number if your
head is spinning it should be because
it's absolute chaos it appears to be
designed to further muck up a system
that parents mediators and Advocates are
desperate to have better clarification
on ultimately child support is supposed
to be in the best interest of the
children
Senate Bill 431 as we just amended it
doesn't do that
Children and Families would be better
served if this body would now wait for
the statutorily required report to be
completed with the most accurate and
up-to-date data
please
press the red button and vote in the
best interest of New Hampshire's
children thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognizes representative Ocala to
this
Bill requires that the the judges only
consider the best interests of the child
as it came to us from the from the
Senate there were the best interests of
the child and other considerations also
supposed to be considered equally with
the best interests of the child so in
cases where it didn't meet those other
qualifications
this adjustment wouldn't be appropriate
even though it was found to be in the
best interest of the child and the first
instance and so there's
so this bill cleans up that issue and it
also as was talked about before when you
have
raising child in two households it costs
more money
and the bill did not increase the amount
of money going towards that raising of
the child for for having two households
and that 120 percent that was talked
about is that increase so more money is
going towards the kids raising of
children in this instance and there was
a talk about
equal
you know households and and one being
rich one not being rich and that is not
uh the purpose of child support the
purpose of Child Support is to raise the
kids not for wealth redistribution and
so we need to make sure that we are
providing people
the means to provide the best
care that's in the best interest of
children end of story and so I hope that
you will vote uh ought to pass with the
a division
[Music]
who requested the Roll Call
roll roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently second it is
officially seconded this will be a roll
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended for Senate Bill 431 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative long for a parliamentary
inquiry
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
ninety percent of cases settle their
child support
if I further know that a group of
professionals volunteered in working out
a guideline that benefits the 10 percent
and reduces conflict then when I press
the red button thank you Mr Speaker
Geo recognized representative D Simone
thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the child support should always be
calculated in the best interest of the
children by increasing funds to raise
those children
and if I know that Senate Bill 431 as
amended assures that the Court's Focus
will be in that interest without
extraneous limitations and finally Mr
Speaker if I am positive that as amended
Senate Bill 431 is completely
and thoroughly in the best interest of
the children then I will push the green
button to support the majority committee
recommendation of ought to pass thank
you Mr Speaker
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 431 it's a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button every oppose
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
while murmur was president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
foreign
also be in order
committee on children and family law to
which was referred Senate Bill 457 enact
establishing a committee to study
non-profit organizations Contracting
with the Department of Health and Human
Services for children services have been
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senator Cody
Belanger for the committee are you ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes haven't the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which those
referred Senate Bill 202 FN
and act prohibiting
the sale of cosmetic projects tested on
animals have we considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment instead of
Don Johnson for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass his name Jane bully open minority
of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I move that we lay
Senate Bill 202 FN on the table that is
a proper motion the motion before risk
is to lay Senate Bill 202 on the table
are you ready
[Music]
a division has been requested members
okay
the motion before is his delay Senate
Bill 202 on the table
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative hunt for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the exemptions
in this bill has con caused a lot of
concern and misunderstanding that I
think it does if Mr Speaker if I know
that at this time the best thing to do
is to press the green button would I do
that
the motion before us is the lay on the
table Senate Bill 202 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button every Pros you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
ball members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
320 voting a eight voting a
majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs do which was
referred Senate Bill 210
an act relative to the sale of
manufactured housing Parks having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass Senator Joyce Weston for the
a minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority a report with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senator
Christina Fargo for the minority of the
committee
the question the motion before us is the
majority committee report of ought to
pass are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
the Journey of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred Senate bill 319fn act relative
to vaccination status and wellness
incentives considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpeding to legislate
Senator Jeffrey greeson for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator Christy Bartlett from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
burles to speak against the committee
report
um I rise today in support of SB 319
scp-319 provides a model on how to
incentivize employers to decrease health
care and premium costs for both
employers and employees it provides an
incentive not a mandate
to employers to ensure that their
employees are fully vaccinated against
covid-19 at the time of enrollment in a
health plan however this model can be
applied to any important Health Care
preventive measure that will save
everyone in the system money and this
bill will sunset at the end of
2023. facts vaccine hesitancy has had a
steep economic cost for granite Staters
best based on preventable
hospitalizations
and deaths in New Hampshire the charge
for each cover for hospitalization
averages over 256
000 for a complex case and over 62 000
for a non-complex case these excess
costs will be passed on to all of us in
increased insurance premiums it also has
a clause for employees with lost wages
and will exacerbate critical label
shortages Drive higher insurance
premiums and increase out of pocket
expenses for both employer employees now
during the peak of the covet endemic due
to bed shortages hospitals were often
unable to treat people with critical
emergencies a dear friend of mine had
extreme a case of extreme pancreatitis
and she was unable to get a hospital bed
for several days while she was in great
pain and even when she got a bed into
the hospital it was several days because
she could have her surgery because again
because a staff shortages and it was
only one surgeon determined that she had
to go in right then and there was she
taken in for her surgery
so that was several days of excruciating
pain other patients found it difficult
to schedule their regular Cancer
Treatments receive follow-up care or to
see a position for necessary procedures
this bill is not a covet bill it is a
health care savings model that can be
utilized for other preventable diseases
it is example of preventative Wellness
as opposed to a sickness model of Health
Care and what do I mean by this our
health care System currently makes a
profit when it performs tests and does
procedures on sick people it is not
rewarded for doing preventive care or
for reducing the overall cost of care
and I'll I will give you an example of
this my husband and I annually go see a
physician in Vidalia Georgia every year
for a wellness exam because this
physician specializes in is in this and
by the way I don't recommend going to
Vidalia Georgia
now after the test it was a two-day
procedure a two-day process
um I found that I had um enlarged not
thyroid nodules that had to be biopsies
thankfully they were benign but they
still need to be monitored today my
husband was found to be low in vitamin
B12 with if left untreated could have
led to premature dementia
cost for the exam was significantly less
than the cost to treat thyroid cancer or
dementia and it was completely covered
by Medicare most health care
organizations in New Hampshire still do
not have well-developed Wellness
programs which could save our health
care System millions of dollars annually
consider this bill that invests in
lowering the cost of care and improving
the health and lives of New Hampshire
citizens let's promote Wellness care in
addition for caring for the ill and New
Hampshire please press the green button
to pass this Wellness Bill thank you
do you recognizer representative Gleason
does remember yield to questions
does the member yield the questions
Senate Bill 319 is not even necessary to
pass because insurance companies can
already offer incentives if they should
choose to do so
secondly
the only thing ever discussed during the
hearings about this bill was covet
vaccine I think we have reached a point
of coveted weariness those who have
received the vaccine have done so those
who don't want to receive the vaccine
probably not going to regardless of the
incentive
thirdly nothing in this bill protects
anyone who should reject any kind of an
incentive regardless of their reason for
wanting it I don't want the gym
membership I don't want the vaccine I
don't want the pizza whatever it is no
one said anything about partaking what
if somebody just doesn't want the
incentive and there's nothing to protect
them from any future discrimination or
any kind of adverse treatment following
rejecting that incentive
so with that I ask you to please press
the green button so we can kill this
Bill thank you does a member yield the
questions
sure remember yields May inquire thank
you Mr Speaker and thank you for taking
my question
um
wasn't it the case at the public hearing
that the insurance commissioner came in
and told us that some insurance
companies wanted this because the
current federal laws and federal
regulations are vague and they needed
the insurance commissioner would need
some type of state law to give them
something some clarity wasn't that the
they had the question of whether or not
they could offer incentives and it was
determined that they can already offer
incentives any kind of confusion I'm not
sure what their confusion actually was
that that I don't know follow-up
remember yield the further questions uh
one last one we're getting weary on the
main foyer
um we go by the text of the bill rather
than necessarily what stated during the
hearing isn't it so that in the text of
the bill that this could be an incentive
for any type of vaccine even past
vaccines that people have got for polio
or smallpox or some other condition so
there's no incentives for
past
vaccines it's only going forward and the
only vaccine ever mentioned was covid so
there's not even an incentive to get
smallpox vaccine and no one since 1969
or 70 in their child regular childhood
vaccinations received a smallpox so why
aren't we incentivizing kids to get the
smallpox vaccine
that's right
thank you for the clarification
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpeding to
legislate the Senate Bill 319
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of any expedient to
legislate on Senate Bill 319
are you ready for the question
synovia Kelly has requested roll calls
that's efficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently it is not
sufficiently seconded this will be a
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexperience of
legislative and Senate Bill 319 this is
a division vote the chair recognizes
representative Weston for a
if I know that insurance companies do
not penalize the customer if they choose
not to take advantage of a cent of an
incentive
and if I know that this is enabling
legislation just designed to encourage
Wellness rather than to treat sickness
and if I know that this will help
insurance carriers to reduce costs and
to keep premiums down would I not now
press the red button to defeat this
motion so know the motion can be made
chair recognize representative hunt for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know this bill is only
Mr Speaker I know this bill uh the
payment would only be made at the time
Mr Speaker if I know this bill will
expire
in 2023
so that there are very limited amount of
checks maybe being paid out
if Mr Speaker if I know that an
insurance company could do it
on their own
if they can scientifically calculate
that it will reduce costs so at this
point Mr Speaker well I now pass the
green button
motion before us is the majority
committee report of annex meeting to
legislate in Senate Bill 319 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button of your opposed
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
179 voting a 150 voting a to committee
majority of the committee on Commerce
and consumer affairs to which was
referred Senate Bill 355 FN an act
requiring online marketplaces to
disclose certain information to
Consumers consider the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
Senate Paul Terry for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative Constance van Houton for
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
Weston to speak against the committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker
Senate Bill 355 would require
high-volume online marketplaces such as
Amazon to collect basic information
about their third-party Sellers and then
to annually verify that that information
is genuine
in the hearing for this bill which by
the way had no testimony in opposition
we heard that Smash and grab threats our
growing concern in New Hampshire and
that online marketplaces provide cover
for sellers of stolen goods
but the much bigger problem is what
retailers call organized retail crime we
heard that thefts are occurring of
truckloads of brand new items still in
their original packaging these items are
then being sold as new online by Shifty
third-party sellers
Additionally the Online Marketplace
provides cover for counterfeit and
pirated goods worth an estimated 500
billion a year in global trade
this is particularly dangerous in the
field of pharmaceuticals with
counterfeit drugs becoming more and more
common
currently on Amazon's site a third-party
seller is able to set up an account with
false information a false tax ID false
address false phone number because that
information is never verified by Amazon
when the buyer then has a product
complaint Amazon famously will return
your money
but as that's as far as they go they
take no responsibility for harm because
they are not really the seller
essentially Amazon will tell you to go
pound sand
this legislation would go a long way
towards providing transparency
accountability and much needed deterrent
to thieves and counterfeiters
so the question is why do we need
interim study
both the New Hampshire Police
Association and the New Hampshire retail
association strongly supported this bill
and consider it Priority legislation
they like this bill as it is and they
see no need to study it further
similar legislation has been passed in
other states because this is a good
solid solution
and then their 12 States considering
they're another 12 States now
considering this business friendly
transparent transparency Focus
legislation
so please vote against interim studies
so that we can move this bill along with
ought to pass thank you
chair recognizes representative Terry to
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
SB 355 FN provides all of us with an
excellent case study on the question of
the proper place
necessity role and timing for government
and in this circumstance our state's
government to become involved in a
matter of Commerce claimed by some to be
begging for our action
the majority of the Commerce and
consumer affairs committee have
thoughtfully and carefully come to the
conclusion that a compelling case cannot
be made at this time for us to accept
the plea for legislative action to
resolve what is claimed by some online
marketplaces to be a problem they and
some consumers are experiencing with
transactions that involve so-called
third-party high volume sellers
as represented To Us by the Bill's
sponsors consumers are being victimized
both by online marketplaces run by
entities such as Amazon and Walmart and
certain third-party sellers with whom
these entities have Arrangements that
permit the third party sellers to Market
their products through the Online
Marketplace
seriously however none of the 19 members
of our committee could identify a single
instance
in which an online marketer refused to
resolve a dispute in their favor
to put this positively the online
marketer accepted responsibility for the
transaction as if it had been their own
and proceeded to make things right
further we did not hear testimony from a
single consumer claiming otherwise and
finally when we asked the representative
of the State's Department of Justice if
he could tell us how many complaints
have been received by his office he said
he was unable to identify any
rather we heard from a handful of Online
Marketplace entities in their lobbyists
who the majority concluded that the
relief they were seeking was not
convincing because in addition to the
distinct and pronounced lack of consumer
complaints the question remains
unresolved as to why the online
marketers seeking our intervention
cannot manage the entirely voluntary
relationships into which they agreed to
enter with third-party sellers unless
they received the assistance of
government and yet another law
simply put why is government needed when
government does not appear to be needed
either for the Online Marketplace
entities or for consumers who may
already utilize existing consumer
protection laws in situations where both
the Online Marketplace entity and the
third party seller fail to act in a
manner deemed unsatisfactory by a
consumer
now admittedly none of us are geniuses
but for the life of us we cannot figure
out why an online Marketplace entities
such as Amazon or Walmart cannot on
their own and all by themselves
decide to terminate their relationship
with any and all third party sellers who
do not and will not practice the same or
even better commitments made to
Consumers as those made by the Online
Marketplace entities themselves
Mr Speaker the clock has run out for us
to receive responses to these perplexing
questions there simply is no
demonstrated in documented crisis with
which government needs to get involved
and to deal with this at this time
so it is for this reason that the
committee's majority recommends and
urges that the House vote interim study
on HB 355 FM thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of interim study on
Senate bill 355.
who requests a roll call
from sonship requests the roll calls
it is not sufficiently seconded this
foreign
motion before us is the majority
committed a report of interim study on
Senate bill 355. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Abel for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that a serious
problem in fact does exist right now
today in New Hampshire and other states
in which organized crime
steals goods from New Hampshire
businesses
and particularly small businesses I
point out to a recent example in
Manchester
and that law enforcement
law enforcement
lacks the tools to identify
and prosecute
these crimes that are that are sold by
that are sold on online retail
sites
and I know that this bill will give law
enforcement
and prosecutors and the victims
of of
the victims who buy buy such products
the ability to obtain restitution to it
to be identified and therefore
to have Bad actors punished
what if I know these things which I do
but I now press the red button
to defeat the motion of interim study so
that we may take action on this problem
by presenting a different motion thank
you very much
chair recognize representative hunt for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that the Commerce committees
primary charge
is to work on the consumer protection
act
if I know the consumer protection act is
if I know Mr Speaker
there are no consumers being harmed here
there's a lot of crime going on
that is Rico organized crime
theft
that belongs if Mr Speaker if I believe
that belongs in the criminal statute
not the consumer protection act which
only guarantees
that you get your money back
if Mr Speaker if I know the people who
are being harmed
are not the consumers but but
corporations the businesses who are
having the theft
and therefore this bill is in the wrong
statute
what I now support the Commerce
committee's interim study in its work to
find the right place for this
legislation when I now press the green
button
motion before us the majority committee
report of interim study on Senate bill
355. this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
of your opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
absolutely
[Music]
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
176 voting yay 155 voting a committee
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which it was referred
Senate Bill 294 refn relative to the
release of a defendant pending trial
this is without recommendation chair
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I'd like
to make a motion of uh make a motion to
table
Senate Bill 294 and I would like a
division vote
calls for a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
foreign
members will be members will be in their
seats
a motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 294 FN
this will be a roll call vote
chair recognizer representative Burke
Mr Speaker
if I know the house tabled an identical
ominous bill in January because it was
unconstitutional
expensive
in unnecessary
if I know the house has already passed a
bail Reform Bill this session that was
worked on by the criminal justice
committee and debated in this body
Mr Speaker
if I also know that this bill disregards
the phrase
innocent until proven guilty
and will hold thousands of granite
Staters in jail before their trial many
of them for crimes that do not carry
jail time
and lastly Mr Speaker if I know on April
13th
of this year the criminal justice
committee spent six and a half hours
with the court system folks talking
about a magistrate system that would fix
the bail commissioner's problem in this
magistrate system will be cheaper
constitutional and will happen next term
would I now press that beautiful green
button to support the house previous
position in table Senate bill 294.
thank you Mr Speaker Joe recognizes
representative Abbas for her
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
there is a floor amendment that will
address the majority of the concerns
just raised by the previous speaker
and Mr Speaker if I know that the policy
provided for in that floor Amendment
would be narrowly applied to only
apply to circumstances where a person
was arrested for a violent crime such as
rape
in domestic violence or sex crimes
against children be brought before a
bail commissioner excuse me brought
before a judge as opposed to a bail
commissioner and Mr Speaker if I know
that this that this bill would not
repeal bail reform and is narrowly
applied to a single section of bail
reform and lastly Mr Speaker if I know
that my friend from Portsmouth who I
sometimes refer to as the dean has a
speech prepared
and I would love to hear her give that
speech should I go ahead and push that
red button
and oppose the motion to table thank you
the motion before us is the table Senate
bill 294. this is a roll call vote here
in favor you'll press a green button of
the opposal press the red button voting
foreign
[Music]
209 voting a 121 voting a Senate Bill
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which was deferred Senate Bill
299 FN act relative to the penalty for
escape having considered the same report
the same
with the recommendation to pay a lot of
pass Senator Terry Roy for the committee
bill on secorini opened a further
Amendment representative Roy offers
and he's recognized to speak to his
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the floor Amendment
before you
you may recognize because it's a bill
that you've already passed it's HB 629
we passed this bill by a two to one
majority and sent it to the other body
where it was apparently
not given good consideration
I feel like this term all of us on both
sides
have put a lot of work into bills where
we convinced the majority of 400 people
to pass a bill
only to have it die for no apparent
reason so we're going to send it again
to give him another chance
this bill passed as I said by a two to
one majority in this house
now as to the
uh
so again I ask you to support the
amendment we already passed it
frankly if you're like me and you're
tired of hearing about
cannabis bills let's send this one more
time and be done with it
the motion before us is the floor the
Roy floor Amendment 1907h
the question is on the floor Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes the eyes have it and the floor
amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the committee report
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety to which was
referred Senate Bill 361 FN the ACT
requiring that bail Commissioners be
reimbursed for mileage traveled in the
performance of their duties considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution so that it's
inexpedient to legislate instead of
Terry Roy for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
Sam John bordenet for the minority of
the committee
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed May
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to request
that Senate Bill 234 the uh Jason Dickey
Suicide Prevention act be special order
till tomorrow morning first thing when
motion is to special order Senate Bill
234 till
the first bill tomorrow morning are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in Senate Bill 234 is
majority of the committee on environment
and agriculture to which was referred
Senate bill 367. relative to regulatory
status of advanced Recycling and
Manufacturing facilities considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment section of
Howard Pearl for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative Megan
the amendment is 1764 H Clinton and
house record 17 pages
74-76. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
that was a postnay
you guys have it in the many amendment
is adopted bills on second reading open
to further Amendment
the amendment is Bixby floor Amendment
1-899-h it's in your seat pockets and
the chair recognizes sen of Bixby to
speak to the amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
the committee adopted the committee
Amendment uh and unanimously but one
reason that some people voted on interim
study on the bill was that Des had had
not had a chance to review the committee
Amendment and this floor amendment is
the result of that review
uh just a quick uh bit of orientation
Advanced recycling is taking Plastics
which are long chain polymers and
breaking them down into small organic
molecules and those organic molecules
can be used to make new plastic they can
also be used as fuel and that brings up
one of the
um
points in the committee amendment that
was clarified in the floor Amendment
which is that in order to count as
advanced recycling
the re the the facility cannot use these
molecules as fuel they have to use them
for recycling any use and the uh the
floor amendment clarifies that any use
of these as fuel within the facility
would count as waste not as fuel
and not as not as product
another issue
that the committee that the floor
Amendment clarify clarifies is uh that
uh there are some right there were some
regulatory changes that the committee
amendment made that Des said did
actually actually didn't uh make sense
in terms of the way that they do the
regulations and those have been changed
to make sure that they're in conformance
with the way that Des works and finally
one of the things that the committee
Amendment does is it indicates how uh
the products of advanced recycling get
used as uh in in terms of waste
reduction goals and Des suggested that
we should also indicate that we the
um
that part of the bill should show where
or should ask a reporting on where the
plastic comes from that gets recycled
because another point of the bill says
that the plastic that gets recycled
should be a priority it should By
Priority come from New Hampshire so
those are the changes that the four
amendment makes and I hope that you
the emotion before us is the Bixby Flora
Amendment
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in a bits before
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass as amended
chair recognizes representative Megan
Murray to speak against the committee
report
this in our world from food packaging to
toys to plastic car seats that expire
let's not forget those plastic building
blocks that are often a late night
Hazard my feet find
I want nothing more than to find a way
to safely and responsibly deal with the
copious amounts of plastic we have in
our society
today I respectfully rise in opposition
to the motion of otpa as the chair of
the subcommittee work group on SB
367 tasked with hearing testimony on the
subject of plastic and chemical
recycling over the past few weeks we had
to very we had the opportunity to hear
from various stakeholders sharing their
hopes desires aspirations and concerns
around the use of plastic Sid's
feedstock and chemically heating
recycling as a regulated industry here
in New Hampshire should we regulate it
absolutely but not in such a harried
manner
ultimately in a four to three bipartisan
vote the bill was recommended for
interim study while it's certainly tried
to create a regulatory framework around
this scientifically complex process of
heating Plastics into a liquid soup of
sorts that would winnow out individual
chemical components into new plastic
items the bill fell short in other areas
and moved too quickly leaving many
questions unanswered questions range
from environmental concerns landfilling
potentialities and consumer safety and
transparency concerns simply put the
bill isn't ready
many Plastics are not yet recyclable in
this way which leads one to wonder if
New Hampshire could be left holding the
bag on rejected Plastics that don't meet
industry specs
and if we could be the destination for
untraceable loads that open the door for
increased rates of disposal our
landfills already contain over 50
percent of out-of-state waste and others
regionally are unready to move forward
countries all over the world are looking
at this process and recognize the need
for strong regulatory Frameworks around
chemical recycling
what does one do with these materials
contaminants how much plastic can one
facility melt or heat in a day week or
month where exactly did the plastic used
for melting come from and how is it
sourced
who stores the data about where it would
come from and in what system how would
this affect our Solid Waste working
group which is already underway
New Hampshire has a more than imperfect
track record when it comes to
contamination Superfund sites and
pollutants affecting everyone from our
military and First Responders to
citizens of entire towns we owe it to
ourselves and each other to pump the
brakes on this bill and craft it more
carefully for these reasons and more I
humbly ask you that you press the red
button in opposition to the motion
before us so that another motion can be
made thank you
which I recognize representative mole of
speak for the committee report
recommendation
for 367. this bill seeks to encourage
innovation in the field of advanced
recycling in New Hampshire and it does
this by creating a clear regulatory
structure for this industry under our
manufacturing laws
how to best manage the recycling in the
ReUse of plastics is a growing priority
for us all and the public has been
asking us for Solutions on how we can
divert Plastics from our landfills
Advanced recycling facilities provide us
with a Cutting Edge
market-based opportunity
to do just that by making it possible to
recycle a wide variety of post-used
plastics into new products particularly
using some Plastics that are currently
not able to be recycled under
traditional methods
during the bill evaluation process the
committee and subcommittee heard
extensive testimony from a variety of
stakeholders
to include New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services
this invaluable testimony enabled our
committee to thoroughly evaluate the
concept of advanced recycling through
this evaluation one of the top
priorities of the committee and the
subcommittee was to understand the
environmental considerations of advanced
recycling
this bill ensures that Advance recyclers
would comply with all state and federal
manufacturer laws and rules that protect
Air Water waste and land use it is
important to note that this bill has the
support of New Hampshire Des
in addition to this bill being a
forward-looking approach to address the
concerns we all share regarding Plastics
filling up our landfills it also
provides us with an opportunity to
attract Innovation and Technical job
growth in our state
the future of post-shoes recycling is a
rapidly expanding field 18 other states
have already passed similar legislation
with current legislation being
considered in New York New Jersey and
Rhode Island
the bipartisan committee amendment that
accompanies this bill represents the
meticulous attention to detail and
careful consideration given to the
concept of advanced recycling
as a testament to the strength of this
bill it also received unanimous
bipartisan support in the Senate
most importantly this bill aligns with
New Hampshire's Waste Management goals
where reuse and recycling are preferred
over landfill waste
I ask house members to support this bill
and to assist the environment and
agriculture committee and its goals of
incorporating creative
economically feasible Solutions into New
Hampshire's waste management practices
by pressing the green button and
supporting the ought to pass motion
thank you
motion before us the majority committed
report of water passes
as amended on Senate Bill 367 a division
has been requested members will take
oh
motion before us as the majority commit
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative
Copeland for a parliamentary inquiry
capital
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that these proposed
that these proposed plastic processing
facilities could in theory reduce the
amount of waste going to landfill and
incinerators in our state but that
important questions remain
namely around getting the most
protective language to Public Health and
the environment while at the same time
balancing the industry's reasonable
desire for fair and appropriate
regulations
Mr Speaker if I also know that by
adopting this bill as it stands we would
be jumping heedlessly ahead of federal
Regulators namely the Environmental
Protection Agency which is at this
moment drafting a regulatory framework
for these proposed chemical recycling
facilities by seeking information more
information than we have currently
available to us here in New Hampshire on
the industrial processes on the products
and the waste byproducts of these
industrial processes and that the
anticipated regulatory ruling would in
fact Aid us
in New Hampshire as we seek to craft
rules around these proposed facilities
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
important stakeholder groups in the
state with long standings such as the
scrap metal recycling industry and the
paper and Forest products industry have
expressed reservations on the language
of this bill and have not had their
chance to testify in a
thoughtful
unhasty deliberative and diligent
legislative process
would I now press the red button and
pause this ought to pass motion so that
interim study motion can be made thank
you Mr Speaker
recognize representative Pearl for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this body has passed
recommended recycling goals for New
Hampshire and is thoughtful in its
approach to address solid waste policy
also if I know that advanced recycling
of plastics is one more step we can take
to reuse currently unrecycled Plastics
rather than sending these Plastics to
our landfills
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
Des supports this bill and is confident
that the amended language gives them the
authority to regulate an advanced
recycling facility would I now press the
green button and support the ought to
pass as amended motion from the
committee
motion before us is the majority
committee report of water passes amended
on Senate bill 367. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposal press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
members president an opportunity to vote
under 98 voting yay 128 voting a
committee on executive departments and
administration which was referred to
Senate Bill 218 an act declaring October
13 as metastatic Breast Cancer Awareness
Day have been considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved as in expedient to legislate
Senator Tony Lucas for the committee
question before us is on the motion of
inexpeding to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
op close nay
the eyes haven't committed reporters
adopted
committee on executive departments
Administration to which those referred
Senate Bill 219 an act declaring the
month of September as kinship care
Awareness Month considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is in expedient
to legislate instead of Jennifer Rhodes
for the committee question before us is
the committee report of inexpeding to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay thank you
the eyes have it and the committed
the majority of the committee on
Executive Apartments Administration to
which was referred Senate Bill 220 act
relative to establishing a committee to
study the licensure of mental health
professionals consider the same report
the same the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass so if Sally fellows
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is in
expedient to legislate so Matthew
sanitasto for the minority of the
committee
the question before us is the majority
committee report of ought to pass are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye as opposed nay
your eyes have it the committee report
majority of the committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred Senate Bill 274 and act
relative to governmental construction
contracts considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it's inexpedient to
legislate Senator Jeffrey goalie for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation not to fill out a pass
from his Antonio agus for the minority
of the committee chair recognizes
representative leakis to speak against
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill would prohibit the requirement
of project labor agreements plas in
state government and state government
assisted construction contracts it would
not affect local contracts that were not
supported by the state
first let me address one of the most
important concerns raised by the
committee of majority the concern is
that because the bill includes any
project in an area subject RSA 79e which
is the community revitalization tax
relief incentive and because some major
federal grants require the use of
project labor agreements New Hampshire
communities would would not be eligible
for these grants for important
infrastructure projects
this would be a valid concern that I
would share if this bill actually
prevented New Hampshire communities from
accepting these grants
the bill contains an exemption that
would certainly apply in these cases
it provides that a government entity May
exempt a particular project contract or
subcontract from the requirements of any
or all of the provisions of the bill if
the governmental unit finds that special
circumstances require an exemption
they would first have a have to have a
public notice and hearing justifying the
need for an exemption the possibility of
losing grants from hundreds of thousands
to a hundred million dollars would
certainly justify such an exemption
over 90 percent of the contractors in
New Hampshire do not operate under a
collective bargaining agreement
these contractors are organized in
various ways
many have their own apprenticeship and
safety programs some are employee owned
some organize it at teams that are
experienced working together to get the
job done well and quickly
they offer attractive pay and benefits
how could they do otherwise in this
environment where it is very difficult
to find trades people for any project if
they offered poor pay or working
conditions they would quickly lose their
employees
nothing in this bill would prevent
contractors that operate under a
collective bargaining agreement from
bidding on and winning these contracts
plas would not benefit the workers with
a pla the benefits and training funds
stay with the Union not the employee
non-union workers on a pla job will
continue will contribute money for union
benefits and training that they will
never receive because the job won't last
long enough for them to vest in those
benefit plans
plas often require the adoption of rigid
work rules that reduce efficiency and
increase costs
construction is a highly regulated
industry with high standards for safety
oversight by OSHA insurance requirements
bonding training standards and more
these standards are enforced by existing
state procurement laws all without plas
When government mandates a pla it can
cost taxpayers an additional 20 percent
or more for construction
our job is to provide the infrastructure
our constituents need without costing
them more than absolutely necessary
New Hampshire is successfully and
efficiently completed many construction
projects over the years without
requiring project labor agreements this
bill would just assured that this
practice continues please join me in
pushing the red button to oppose the it
the motion committee motion so another
chair recognizes representative goalie
honorable colleagues Senate Bill 274
will put New Hampshire's ability to
receive competitive grants for
construction projects in jeopardy
and make fulfilling the conditions of
certain grants impossible
this bill seeks to prospectively
prohibit project labor or compute
Community benefit language and
construction contracts using State
Monies
testimony indicated that in the history
of our state there has never been a
state contract with these provisions
the definition of government-assisted
project in this bill includes any
project in the area subject to RSA 79e
the community revitalization tax relief
incentive
this would include the Economic
Opportunity Zone in Manchester centered
around where the advanced regenerative
manufacturing Institute is currently
located
the city of Manchester
currently received five hundred thousand
dollars from the buildback better
Regional ChalleNGe Program to plan and
establish a cluster located within and
around the city to grow the regenerative
medicine industry by boosting production
and distribution of regenerative tissue
or in organs
Manchester is now competing for phase
two to receive up to 100 million dollars
for a government-assisted contract to
construct a biofabrication manufacturing
facility and other items
on page 21 of the notice of funding
opportunity executive summary
for this grant one of the requirements
to be is the use of project labor
agreements
blocking this grant moving forward on
ideological grounds would deprived New
Hampshire of these funds and the local
jobs they would generate it would not be
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
even had testified in opposition to this
section
and the problem is not unique to this
one Grant if this bill were to become
law
New Hampshire D.O.T would likely be less
able to access other competitive grants
with similar requirements such as the
rebuilding American infrastructure with
sustainability and Equity Grant
program investment and jobs
the national infrastructure project
assistant grants program the nationally
significant multimodal Freight and
highways project grants program and the
rural surface Transportation grants
program
some of the rules governing the awarding
of infrastructure grants are still in
the process of being written and it is
premature and dangerous to pass this
type of legislation now without knowing
the unintended consequences especially
when a consequence could be a burden on
the New Hampshire taxpayer
and I ask if plas are good enough for
large companies such as Walmart and
Toyota motor corporations to use on
their construction projects that might
please be a tool New Hampshire would
want to employ at some point in the
future
why take that option away
I believe we as legislators should be
supporting bills that seek to solve
problems that our state is actually
facing
and as New Hampshire has never had a
project labor agreement this bill seems
only to add government red tape and
further regulation to the New Hampshire
construction industry
and let me repeat New Hampshire has
never mandated apla for the state
funded construction projects and its
history
so there is no need to prohibit
something that has never happened
passing to house passing Senate Bill 274
will also jeopardize New Hampshire's
ability to receive millions of dollars
in federal funding for infrastructure
money that is needed to repair our
deteriorating roads and bridges
please support the bipartisan vote of
inexpedient to legislate and press the
green button Mr Speaker I asked for a
division
a division has been requested members
foreign
call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
man
thank you
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of an expedient to
legislate
on Senate bill 274. it's a roll call
vote
chair recognizes representative turcott
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that free market principles
and competition will always produce the
best costs on state construction
projects and therefore will Advantage
our taxpayers
and if I also know that contractors who
use or do not use organized labor in
their Workforce should receive neither
preferential or detrimental treatment in
the bidding process
and if I know this bill would not
prevent communities of the state from
accepting federal grants that require
project labor agreements
finally Mr Speaker if I know that the
decision to utilize or not utilize any
project labor agreements should be at
the discretion of the contractor with
the bidding winning bid and one of that
I now press the red button to overturn
the current motion so another motion can
be made thank you Mr Speaker
which I recognize representative merner
labor agreement and construction project
what makes this bill a solution
searching for a problem and if I know
the definition of government assisted
project in this bill would block a 100
million dollar grant that the city of
Manchester has applied for the buildback
better challenge programmed to support
the advance of regenerative
manufacturing industry and Mr Speaker if
I know the similar Provisions in the
rebuilding America infrastructure with
sustainability and Equity grant program
and other Federal infrastructure grants
would block New Hampshire ability to
successfully compete for multi-million
dollar grants badly needed for our
state's infrastructure when I now push
the green button for the strong
bipartisan minority
the motion before us is majority commit
a report of in expedient to legislative
Senate bill 274. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
yeah
wall members president an opportunity to
177 voting a 154 voting a committee
majority of the committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
before at Senate Bill 325 an act
relative to local Organization for
emergency management and First
Responders having considered the same
report the same the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass representative
Stephen Pearson for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
Fallen resolution resolved that it is
inexpeding to legislate Senator Mark
Allegro from the minority of the
committee
chair recognizes representative Allegro
speak against the committee report
the house will be
Senate Bill 325 purports to Define First
Responders and includes First Responders
in the definition of Emergency
Management and local Organization for
Emergency Management however
first responder
is already well defined
you can look in any dictionary or online
source and for instance here's
Merriam-Webster is conventional the
sources that defines a first responder
as a person such as a police officer or
EMT who is among those responsible for
going immediately to the scene of an
accident or emergency to provide
assistance
what this bill actually does is it
expands it expands the definition of
first responder
to include many service providers
Downstream of the actual first response
whether their actions come into play
hours or for some other indefinite
period after the true First Response
during our deliberations
it was mentioned several times that this
was a uh
a ceremonial or symbolic recognition
but the ramifications of expanding
definitions are not just symbolic
those expanded definitions we all know
we all know
they subsequently impact salaries
benefits
promotions
training organization
existing law and other bills under
consideration
here's a perfect example
in committee the very next bill that we
was entirely directed at First
Responders
the bill had a cost and that cost would
now be expanded if we expand the
definition of First Responders words
have meaning
make no mistake about it
the continual expansion of definitions
like this means more costs
so with that I'll ask you to please
press
the red button
to vote this bill down thank you very
much as a member yield to questions
remember yields was inherit any money
inquired
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question it
sounds like it's a pretty clear issue
here what we're doing if this bill were
to pass is we pushing an unfunded
mandate onto the towns and counties and
therefore should be considered
unconstitutional
well that's actually a good point thank
you very much for making that point
again uh we're playing around with
language and words do have meaning
and I hate to use that old expression
unintended consequences but for every
bill that defines or that mentions uh
First Responders yes there's the
possibility that we're going to pass an
chair recognize Revenue Steve and
Pearson to speak for the committee
report
thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues I'm not entirely sure how
this bill has been Twisted to the state
that that it seems to be thought of but
here's what it is during a declared
State of Emergency the definition of
first responder has been adjusted to
assist in the more rapid reimbursement
of federal funds from FEMA that is what
this bill is it has nothing to do with
employment classification it has nothing
to do with the pension system it has
nothing to do with the rate of which
people get paid all this does is it adds
a certain group which is mostly the dot
into that definition during a declared
state of emergency for the purpose of
federal reimbursement
that is what this bill is
period there's no downshifting there's
no costs associated people aren't
getting raises off of this it is simply
a classification for the federal
government to recognize what we're doing
locally when it comes to FEMA
reimbursement period
that's all thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is majority
committee report a lot of pass on Senate
bill 325.
are you ready for the question
okay president Silvia requests the roll
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
players
motion before is the majority committee
report about a pass in Senate Bill 325
this is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes the representative
speaker
during the meaning of a term like first
responder
is not just symbolic because when you
change a classification like that
there are all kinds of Downstream fiscal
and otherwise impacts
that we can't even begin to calculate
would I then press the red button so
that another motion can be made thank
you
chair recognize reps in a McGuire for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill merely creates a temporary
classification for the purposes of
including all the First Responders to a
particular emergency in the command
center and in the emergency organization
and if I know that it does not affect
anyone's pay pension or other possible
areas would I not support
the idea of getting more Federal money
for our local communities and push the
motion before us is the majority
committee report about a pass in Senate
Bill 325 this is a roll call vote you're
in favor you'll press the green button
to be opposed or press a red button
foreign
[Music]
well Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote
248 voting a 84 voting a committee
chair recognizes the representative
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I want
to remind everybody May 22nd May 22nd at
the Anheuser-Busch facility is the
legislators charity softball game
we want to encourage everybody to
participate reach out to either myself
Jim majory representative Tim Lang if
you want to play
it is a recommended suggested 50
donation all donations will be collected
and then spread among the Liberty house
in Manchester Haven and the Nashua
Center will be supporting veterans and
victims of domestic violence and we
encourage everyone to come out to this
absolutely nonpartisan fun event thank
you very much Mr Speaker
foreign
[Music]
business
ES
[Music]
foreign
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was required
Senate Bill 33 FN
enact establishing a committee to study
and make recommendations relative to the
office of professional licensure and
certification and the licensure
professionals under boards councils
commissions within the office relative
to the boxing and wrestling commission
relative to the expiration of terms of
the board of forested members having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment as if Diane schuette
George
the question is on the majority
committee Amendment
1732h printed in house record 17 Pages
69 through 70. are you ready for the
question on the majority committee
Amendment all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
majority committee amendment is adopted
the bills on second reading open to
further Amendment
a brahmy floor Amendment
1-863h printed in house record 17 Page
70. which I recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Amendment 18638 simply amends
amendment 1732h that just passed a
second ago on a Voice vote by changing
the composition of the Joint Committee
with the Senate that was established by
the amendment we just passed
this amendment adds two members of house
Ways and Means Committee and one
additional member of the House Edna
committee to the Joint Committee the
housewives and Means Committee until
recent years was involved in setting
licing fees for Myriad of professional
boards
this Duty was shifted to the office of
professional licensure and certification
over the last several years in
preparation for the house Ways and Means
Committee having hearing on a companion
bill Senate Bill 313 that was called for
the cleanup of our statutes removing
fees from statue we came across House
Bill 330 the bill we're talking about
here as well as the amendment 1732.
which called for the joint study
committee to review finding sources and
fees setting Authority among many other
things the Ways and Means Committee
agreed in a bipartisan fashion that we
should be on this joint study committee
given our expertise in this area
I attempted to get the language of this
amendment that we're talking about here
into Amendment 1732 h
so a floor member would not be needed
but I was too late
when the charity of the Edna my friend
from Epson
came to testify in ways and means on the
other bills and the bill 313 she blessed
the idea of this amendment and being
brought forward as a floor Amendment
with with Ways and Means and Edna in
sync in a very partisan way let's
approve this amendment on a quick Voice
question before us is the abramly four
Amendment 1-863-h
questions on the amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
I was supposed nay the eyes have it in
the abrami four amendment is adopted
question before us now is the auto
passes amended motion on Senate Bill 33
oh are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye those opposed nay
the guys have it in the committee report
back
majority of the committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred Senate Bill 333 enact relative
to licensure of case management service
providers have been considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation at the bill
ought to pass with Amendment Senator
Carol McGuire for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment recommendation Bill
ought to pass with amendments in William
Marsh from the minority of the committee
majority committee amendment is
1694h printed in house record 17 Page
70. are you ready for the question on
the majority committee Amendment all
those in favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the majority
committee amendment is adopted
Senator O'Brien offers floral Amendment
bills on second meeting open to further
Amendment
so Brian office floor amendment 1914h in
your seat pockets
and the chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker and good afternoon
colleagues
it gives me great pleasure to bring
forward this floor Amendment although I
know sometimes four amendments can be
difficult uh in the timeliness to
swallow but this is a very important
issue this plural Amendment Echoes
exactly what the house voted on not once
but twice
what just to help you refresh
this act here renews A Promise made by
the state to municipalities and restores
the state contribution of a portion of
retirement costs of teachers
firefighters and local police
its purposes in the hopi's local
property tax burden provided property
tax relief to cities and towns and
enhance public education and Public
Safety thus this bill is so named the
property tax relief Act of 2022.
now why are we rehashing this type of
discussion
it seems that you know when I grew up I
grew up in the three Deca and you could
always hear what the neighbors were
doing or you could choose to ignore
but people who live on the other side of
the wall
are choosing to ignore the wills
of the people of this house
this house got it right
it was not voted once again like I say
it was voted on twice and passed it went
through the separate committees and came
forward and passed
it even went to the other group
and it passed their mirror of what we
call the Edna Committee of a four to one
vote
except it got tabled in the Senate
now what is supposed to replace it is a
one-time seven-high percent tax relief
but those of you that like me wear two
hats
one being the state representative and
one being a City municipal official I'm
vice president of the board of aldermen
when we work a budget how can you take a
one-year rollback from the state and
apply it to the budget yet not have your
budget look like a roller coaster
what to say excuse me what the other
group I almost said that word but what
the other group
kind of wants us to do is go on that
roller coaster ride well if you want
that go to Disney
but in the reality world this house got
it right we listened to the taxpayers
who demanded relief those of you again
that wore two hats you know exactly what
I'm talking about
so we need to have level budgeting so
give the opportunity to our communities
and political Subs divisions to level
off their particular budget this needs
to be more than a single year fix
so therefore I urge you to unite again
with me as we have done in the past
and speak with the loud voice that it
can permeate the wall over here
and make them realize that we speak
United that our constituents who are
taxpayers need property tax relief
particularly after what we all went
through with covid other type of things
and other issues that are draining
municipalities budgets
this is timely and effective to the
citizens of our state and I urge you all
to unite with me and support this
amendment a bipartisan Amendment
to bring back home relief to our
taxpayers thank you Mr Speaker and Mr
Speaker may I call for a roll call
please
I think we got a lot of work Mr Speaker
so I say no member does not yield
thank you Mr Speaker
and while I agree with the previous
representative that we have sent this to
the Senate
they have actually passed
for one year the exact same amount that
he wants to send so that this would
duplicate that and double the amount
even with a budget surplus I don't think
that's what we want
well maybe we do but I it's not what I
want the other thing is that the
the matter of State contributions to
local Retirement Systems will be dealt
with
for this year by a one-time payment and
for next year it it will be as it ought
to be in the budget rather than in a
separate bill in a committee that
doesn't really deal with money so I hope
you'll reject this floor Amendment
allow the
other bills that we have passed on this
exact same issue be dealt with
appropriately
the motion before us is the O'Brien
percent of O'Brien has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
Instagram
members will take their seats also come
the motion before us is the O'Brien
floor Amendment
it's a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Brian
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that a
promise made is the promise kept is the
guidelines the good men and women of
integrity
and that this if I also know that this
house voted not once
but twice and about hopefully to do it a
third time baby in support this
particular bill
and if I also know there's nowhere that
I can see any doubling or no doubling is
intended into this
but let's would you then go with me and
press the green button and send a
unified voice that we have done in the
past
over to the other body to let our
intentions be heard and supported thank
you Mr Speaker
Jay recognizes representative McGuire
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
it just had 47 million dollars to
municipalities as a share of their
retirement contributions and if I know
that if we add this
to this amendment we will
create the need to send an additional 47
million dollars which we don't have
would I not press the red button and
oppose this amendment
question before us is the O'Brien floor
Amendment
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
the voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend to the state of the
vote
170 voting yay 164 voting a the O'Brien
house will be in order
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended
are you ready for the question
the division has been requested members
stay in your seats members take your
seats
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended
this is a division vote
chair recognizes the sin of likas for a
thank you Mr Speaker
um
the decision on the amendment which was
just adopted has been made and so that's
a done deal but on the rest of the bill
if I know that uh DHHS no longer
believes that they have the authority to
license
um case management agencies for home and
community-based care and if I know that
it's critical to continue to license
these agencies in order to get Medicare
okay
all right and if I know it's critical to
continue to licensing these uh agencies
in order to get the Medicare money to
support people living in the community
rather than nursing home and to save the
state money and if I believe that the
other body will accept the language and
the majority amendment that we have
adopted
and it's likely to reject the language
in the minority one which we're not
coming to
but if I also know that um I really
don't
want to be uh sending extra spending
extra State money on the
retirement uh would I have a difficult
decision and uh probably press the red
chair chair recognized representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that Senate Bill
333 will clarify
Case Management Services providers and
is much needed and if I also know as
amended that we are going to withhold
the house position on the state paying
their portion of the retirement system
would I press the green button thank you
motion before us is auto pass has
amended on Senate bill 333.
this is going to be a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
question
all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend
under 95 voting yay 139-49 committee
majority of the committee on executive
departments Administration to which was
enact establishing October 2022 is
eczema Awareness Month having considered
the same report the same but the
following Amendment and the
recommendation to fill out a password
Amendment
Carol McGuire for the majority of the
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that as any
expedient to legislate representative
Peter Smith for the minority of the
committee the amendment is 1645h printed
in house record 17 Pages 73 and 74. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
who requested the division
representative Schmidt requests a
exactly
motion before is the majority committee
report the water passes amended on
Senate bill 358.
chair recognizes representative McGuire
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill as amendment has as amended has
nothing to do with eczema Awareness
Month
and if I know that all it does is
increase the size of the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules in order to decrease the
outrageous workload that it imposes on
its members and that it
and if I know that this might possibly
get more people interested in
administrative rules you're all welcome
to would I not press the green button
thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of water passes an
amended on Senate bill 358. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposal
press the red button warning stations
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
208 voting a 123 voting a committee
majority committee on
executive apartments and administration
to which those referred Senate Bill 382
and act relative to licensure
requirements for Telehealth services and
relative to licensure of Physicians
Physicians assistants through
reciprocity agreements having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation at the bill on a pass
Senator William miles from the majority
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved as in
expedient to legislate
representative Matt's son of tasto for
the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative sanitasto for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this bill prohibits
Telehealth services from out of state
providers who are unlicensed in New
Hampshire
while the bill allows for reciprocity I
believe that many out-of-state providers
might not bother to comply with the with
our bureaucracy because it's
unenforceable and because the New
Hampshire Telehealth Market is Tiny
compared to the global market it's
unlike Licensing in the way electrician
who moves here is bound to the New
Hampshire Market a Telehealth provider
has access to the entire world and for
the you know uh 1.4 million people here
it may not be worth it for them to
comply with our rules
um so either way this will increase
costs and reduce choice for Telehealth
patients in New Hampshire so I ask you
to vote no and uh Mr Speaker asked for a
do you remember yielded questions
I will yield for questions yes
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative I was a big supporter in
Telehealth for veterans which is a
win-win for veterans moving into the
state that we pass this legislation uh
was cheaper they didn't have a
Telehealth person
why would we not do it if we're doing it
for veterans who are successful why
would we not do it for the rest of the
people of New Hampshire
I guess I don't understand this uh Bill
makes licensing required it prohibits uh
remember you'll do another question
uh yeah I will wait for the question
thank you representative I might have
missed interpreted if it just deals with
licensing I understand but you were
asking a second question I I just want
to make sure that we are treating
everyone else I mean I'm a veterans
activist I just want to make sure the
legislation treats everyone else the
same when it comes to that Telehealth
since it was a win-win would you agree
for the veterans that's right
uh I think you know that Telehealth
service if somebody wants it veteran or
not they should uh be able to you know
take advantage of those services
thank you so much representative for
taking my question uh were you aware
that on a very similar Bill the
licensing department of the State of New
Hampshire uh testified that around 44 of
New Hampshire residents rely on out of
state Telehealth medical professionals
for their therapy and if we were not to
pass a bill like that we would be almost
endangering half of the population and
dropping their services
uh yes I'm aware that many people in New
Hampshire already use Telehealth
services and this could cut them off
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise today in support of the strong
bipartisan Edna recommendation of ought
why do we need to identify the site of
service for Telehealth I agree entirely
with the representative who just asked
the question we need to treat everyone
the same
so long as Medical Care is delivered
without incident everyone's happy
and we really don't have to license
these people it doesn't actually matter
the problem is this is the real world
this bill clarifies the site of service
for medical services is the physical
location of the patient
for 31 States this is already
established law if you look at RSA 329c
colon 1 you can read part of the
interstate medical licensure compact
which we in several other states have
adopted 31 States in total
which states the compact also adopts the
prevailing standard for licensor and
affirms that the practice of medicine
occurs where the patient is located at
the time of the physician patient
encounter and therefore requires the
physician to be under the jurisdiction
of the State Medical Board where the
patient is located
similar Provisions are in other
interstate compacts including the nurse
licensure compact RSA 326b colon 46.
every nurse practicing in a party state
must comply with the state practice laws
of the state in which the patient is
located at the time care is rendered
if we pass this bill we will treat all
50 states the same and not just 31.
however not all States including the
state of Massachusetts
have yet adopted the compact
this is important especially when
complications ensue
as without the site of service being
defined it would be unclear which courts
of resolved malpractice claims
or which governing boards would impose
discipline when necessary
if it's not clearly defined
providers could be subject to Double
Jeopardy in some cases
let me clarify with an example
consider the case of an older man with
he might consult with Dr Google
and get an inexpensive online
most of the time the pills come
they work well and when everything is
but one thing I learned in a long
medical career
is sometimes things do not go well
sometimes they go very wrong
both from the package insert and from
personal experience taking care of
patients
I know occasionally after Viagra a man
suddenly and permanently goes
permanently blind from non-arteritic
we call it niom
the one patient I had with this was not
a happy camper
and bad results often result in
but if we never defined what
jurisdictionless the site of service in
which courts would one Sue
and what if there really was malpractice
such as an excessive dose prescribed
after all if one is good isn't two
better
which Board of Medicine would apply
disciplinary action
who would have educational requirements
this is a huge and completely
unnecessary can of worms I ask you not
to open it
please support the strong 13-6
bipartisan recommendation of Edna and
vote green on this Bill thank you so
remember yield the questions
for what reason to memorize I'd like to
make a motion stage of motion yes I
would like to table SB 382
it is a proper motion
a division has been requested
roll call has been requested where it
was an oblasic is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
there also be in order
the motion before us is to table Senate
bill 382.
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know this will increase
costs and prevent patients from using
their provider of choice
then when I press the green button and
vote to table The Spill thank you
chair recognizes representative Marsh
for parliamentary inquiry
speaker if I know we
know with the debate and we know that
not defining the site of service in the
case of
incidents
will only create a huge can of worms
that will be very difficult to untangle
would I not push the red button on the
tabling motion so we can vote on this
Bill thank you
motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 382 it's a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're supposed to press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
amazing
representative
well members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
144 voting a 187-49 the tabling motion
fails
the motion before us now is
ought to pass on Senate bill
382.
all those in favor say aye
[Music]
house will be in order
I've already banned the gamble the
majority of the committee on executive
departments Administration to which was
referred Senate Bill
38397 an act relative to the mental
health counseling Compact and Interstate
Compact for the placement of children
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment and Stephen Pearson
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following Amendment a recommendation to
Bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator William Marsh for the minority
of the committee majority amendment is
17598 printed in House Records 17 Page
83. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass
as amended the chair recognizes
representative Allegro to speak against
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to this bill
you'll hear the pros of it
but there was also some distinctive
committee minority opinions arguing
against it and you won't hear those and
that's why I've risen today to speak
first is the idea in this and in other
interstate compacts New Hampshire seeds
its power to a board a board could be 10
it could be 35 other states the bottom
line is is that instead of having
control over our own procedures we seed
to other states
now uh so it was brought up that simple
much more simple reciprocity agreements
would do better Justice to the state of
New Hampshire I agree with that argument
and there's a second argument that goes
along those lines as well and that has
to do with part one Article 28 of the
State Constitution which says that the
assessment of fees for instance fees
well any charges right the state
constitution discusses any charges uh
levied on the population but in this
case it's fees on both compact member
states and on licensees uh part one
Article 28 expressly prohibits charges
without the consent of the people or the
legislature so this bill not only seeds
power to other states but it violates
our own state constitution
there's another point to be made
and it's not going to be a popular one
to discuss but it's nevertheless true
and I've laid down a marker for myself
I'm laying it down for you here today
even if you choose to not accept my
opinion on this one I want you to think
about it in the future
and that is that this bill also violates
New Hampshire statute
specifically in relation to uh divisive
Concepts a bill that we just a language
that we just passed into law in the last
session
what do I mean
well I knew I'd get a few grumbles on
this one
what do I mean
well if you look at the requirements to
enter the compact
I forget which particular number it is
but the training requirement insists
that compact members licensees undergo
social and cultural diversity training
now
God I love that house will be in order
now what is social and cultural
diversity training well we know that
under any other name it's still critical
race Theory it's still a divisive
concept also be in order
these abhorrent teachings
teaching racist teachings
come under many names now ever since
across the country they were found out
it's something of a chameleon right now
it it's also known as
um social and cultural diversity
training
social emotional learning
equity and inclusiveness training and if
you don't believe that these are shifts
of spots the member will suspend
the point of order Mr Speaker this has
nothing to do with the bill
uh Mr Speaker it does I just got through
saying that we're violating state law
specifically the language dealing with
divisive Concepts I
I
have not read the bill so I'm not quite
I think qualified to make a judgment one
way or the other but all I would suggest
is
I'll try to get to the point a little
and it propagates divisive Concepts
by forcing this is embedded in the bill
it's embedded in the bill that this kind
of training is required so again I'm
laying down the marker for myself I
cannot
and will not ever again vote for a bill
that places these kinds of requirements
upon licensees or upon State compacts
I'm laying down the market for myself
like I said
under whatever name that's being passed
off at the moment
and I hope you'll join me by voting no
on this bill and its required teachings
thank you thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues
this is um
this is a bit of a heavy bill
modifies the original bill
what does some what this bill in its
is it primarily does two things and I'll
speak to it in two parts IT addresses
first off the mental health counseling
compact New Hampshire is a small state
we cannot be expected to have experts in
everything
and certainly when it comes to mental
health there are folks
that need specific and targeted
treatment
so what this Mental Health compact does
is it opens up
New Hampshire's residents to that
specific and targeted treatment that
they may need from someone say in
Wisconsin
or Alabama
as we're all very much aware
the problems in the Mental Health
Community have been exacerbated
in the last five years over
things that have occurred
and the recognition of this problem
has really come to the Forefront in a
lot of areas
[Music]
first part of the bill does that's the
Mental Health compact
it is created in a standard form that is
fairly similar to those of us that are
familiar with
the second part of my Amendment
to what we do
with the placement of children
the amendment removed
a provision to enter the state into a
mental or excuse me a child placement
compact
and we've removed it so I won't touch on
it
but there are a couple of elements that
are extraordinarily critical
right now that were put into this
amendment
that
in conversations with the folks at child
and family law have have expressed to me
the absolute Paramount
Paramount changes to what's going on we
all have seen the news we all are aware
of the current problem that we have
and it's unfortunate that it takes an
act in an event for us to make a change
but sometimes that just that's just how
it is we try to be proactive and we
so this part the second part of what is
now Senate Bill 397
I can I can in the utmost way urge you
to at least think about this part of it
the Mental Health compact
you may be familiar maybe not
but this the second half of this that
involves
an element in the current state compact
for the place of of children that has
been in utter utter failure for the
State of New Hampshire will be fixed
in this
and I ask you to please support that
a motion before us is the majority
Committee reported want to pass as
amended once
Adam Silber requests a roll call is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
[Music]
the motion before it says ought to pass
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes the representative
Mr Speaker
if I knew that New Hampshire had a law
against the propagation of divisive
Concepts
and if I knew that SB 397 required the
teaching of precepts of critical race
Theory would I then press the red button
chair recognized representative goalie
speaker
if I know this bill will allow New
Hampshire to enter into the mental
health counseling Compact and Mr Speaker
if I know New Hampshire will be the 10th
state to join and therefore will enact
the compact
and Mr Speaker if I know this will
increase access
to mental health counseling
and finally Mr Speaker if I know as
amended that an important section of the
compact for the placement of children is
added in statute requiring home visits
of children placed in foster care across
state lines
then Mr Speaker would I press the green
button
motion before it's a majority committee
report of water passes amend an
incentive 397. it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose or press the red
button warning stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
202 voting yay 132 voting a committee
majority of committee on Executive
Department's Administration to which was
referred Senate bill 450. act relative
to prescription drug affordability board
have been considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
Senator Tony leak is for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass
Senator William Marsh from the minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative deshays
uh thank you Mr Speaker and colleagues I
rise today against the committee's
recommendation of interim study and in
support of Senate Bill 450 a bill that
seeks to improve the prescription drug
affordability board this board comprise
of experts in the prescription drug
field recommends ways for the state to
address the precipitous increase in
prescription drug prices
the board is charged with collecting
data and annually reporting its
recommendations to the state this
includes prescription drug spending
targets strategies for optimization of
affordability of prescription drugs the
progress of implementing those
recommendations and the annual net
spending by public payers on
prescription pharmaceutical drugs the
purpose of Senate Bill 450 is to make
meaningful updates to ensure the board
can properly serve Granite Staters
specifically this bill creates a
non-lapsing fund to collect already
established fees already established
fees to pay the board's expenses makes
it easier for a quorum to be formed and
establishes the executive director's
position as an unclassified position it
also creates an appeals process for
decisions made by the board this will
help strike a balance between the needs
of patients and businesses while making
prescription drugs more affordable a
concern shared by 85 percent of granted
Staters over the age of 45. some
described drive this bill as the goal of
one political party this couldn't be
farther from the truth most the language
currently in Senate Bill 450 was from a
Republican's Amendment who presides on
the other side of the wall behind me SB
450 has co-sponsors from both parties
when the prescription drug affordability
board was signed into law by Governor
Chris sununu on July 18 2020 he
described it as quote bipartisan
legislation lowering prescription drug
costs for granted Staters end quote he
even took the time to go to the
committee and speak in favor of the
legislation speak in favor of this board
he showed this resounding report support
in committee and has done so
continuously since plus decreasing drug
prices has always been a bipartisan goal
because it affects everyone no matter
their party affiliation this nonpartisan
board has been a great start to actually
creating real solutions to improve the
lives of granite Staters and to make it
so that they have more affordable drugs
and actually introduced some free market
reforms like getting drugs from Canada
and things of that nature
um heck I mean maybe the prescription
affordability board will one day make
Ivermectin more affordable for future
prescription owners nonetheless I urge
everyone to click the ruby red button
and vote no on the committee's
recommendation of interim study so a new
motion can be brought forward thank you
chair recognizes representative Lee
because we speak for the committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker
earlier this year the house dealt with a
related bill concerning the prescription
drug affordability board and voted to
send it to interim study as we're asking
for this bill the majority recommends
the same for this bill for similar
reasons we would all like to see lower
prices for prescription drugs that goal
is not the question the question is is
this likely to achieve it
um
the board and the expansion of the staff
that this bill in part provides for is
unlikely to achieve that goal we heard a
lot of testimony concerning the problems
people had paying for prescriptions that
they need I'm very sympathetic to those
concerns the problem is is the board can
only directly influence the cost that
the state pays for drugs purchased for
its employee health coverage
and the biggest way it can influence
that is by prohibiting the state from
purchasing drugs if the suppliers won't
meet the price the board demands this
could result in those in the health plan
being denied access to drugs even if
their doctor believes they need them
the department of administrative
Services has already gotten better
prices for prescription drugs for the
State Health Plan by putting them out to
Bid And by in some cases using reverse
auctions to keep the cost down
expanding this particular versus
auctions in the future may be possible
but may require some legislative changes
and that can be considered for next year
but there already have been benefits in
this area
the bill would create a highly paid
position of executive director make
significant changes to fees and would
establish a non-lapsing fund supporters
described the executive director they
would like to hire as a unicorn meaning
they would need a rare combination of
skills and therefore a high salary would
be required to attract them
some of the changes to fees in this bill
are contradictory the board is given the
power to Levy fees and the ability to
spend them with a little oversight even
with all that the bill does not include
a fiscal note which it should and will
not be reviewed by house finance or ways
and means
for these and other reasons the majority
of the committee believes is very
complicated issue requires study by the
house and any bill on this should be
carefully reviewed through the entire
legislative process
please join me in pressing the green
button to support the committee's
recommendation of interim study thank
you please remember yield to questions
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of interim study on
a division has been requested members
motion before us is the majority
committee report of interim study on
Senate bill 450. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative ballot
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues
if I know that Senate Bill 450 is
necessary
for the efficient functioning of a board
we created just two years ago and if I
know that that board is self-funded and
creates zero expense for our state
and if I further know that the bill
passed in the other body
was done so with a unanimous bipartisan
support
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that in
hearings not a single individual nor
organization registered any opposition
to SB 450
would I not now push the red button so
that we might proceed with another
motion thank you Mr Speaker
Geo recognizes represent Maguire for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
everybody wants lowered prescription
prices
but if I also know that the prescription
drug affordability board is unlikely to
do anything to low lower prescription
drug prices
that is not already being done
if I know that this bill will charge
everyone in the prescription drug
business
a lot of money in order to support a
highly paid administrator
and if I know that the New Hampshire
prescription drug Market is a tiny
sliver of the uni the entire United
States market and that anything we do
will not affect
drug prices to any great deal
and if I know that there are
administrative issues with this board
that need to be dealt with would I not
press a green button and send it to
interim study
motion before us is the majority
committed report of interim study on
Senate bill 450. this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
hmm
of all members present an opportunity to
vote
164 voting a 168 voting a
Mr Speaker I Rise for a motion
State your motion I move on to pass on
Senate bill 450.
and ask
[Music]
Senator Bert has requested a roll call
as that's ifad is sufficiently seconded
for what reason to memorize
State your motion to table Senate bill
450.
I'm sorry the question's already been
put
the questions already been put
so we cannot accept another motion at
the motion before was his ought to pass
on Senate bill 450. this is going to be
a roll call vote
Jay recognizes representative goalie for
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know
this bill doesn't change
what the board does
but it clarifies
some things that are currently in
statute
and if I know
that it changes the position
of executive director from classified to
unclassified
and also increases the number of
alternates on the board
and most importantly ads and appeals
process
to this board
then what I now press the green button
so we can move this along thank you
question before us is an ought to pass
motion on Senate Bill 450 this is a roll
call vote you're in favor you'll press
the green button of your poster press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
wall members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
the committee report of ought to pass is
adopted
what reason does it member rise Mr
Speaker I haven't vote on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration and ask the
body to vote no
motion before us is reconsideration on
House Bill 450.
Senate bill 450.
the motion before us is to reconsider
motion on the Senate bill 450. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposal
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
role
150 voting a 175 voting a the motion for
for what reason is memorized Mr Speaker
I Rise to make a motion State your
motion thank you Mr Speaker I moved to
special order
SB 399
from its place on the calendar to
the motion is to move Senate Bill 399 to
the next
bill
correct would you like to speak to your
motion
thank you Mr Speaker
and certain events outside
of our control have taken place this
week and therefore there is particular
reason to address this matter in
addition as we speak about timing we do
know that many well some members of this
body are going to be unable to stay
tomorrow until the end of the day not
knowing when we will get there when we
would ordinarily reach bills that were
taken off the consent calendar and for
those two reasons I would ask as a
courtesy that the members of this body
support my motion
the motion is to special order Senate
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
[Music]
there's been a request for it over it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
question to the speaker
question Mr Speaker is it normally
presence on something like this that we
vote if a member cannot be there that we
know for a fact is going to be speaking
I've seen numerous reasons for special
ordering
the motion before us is a special order
Senate Bill 399 for our next order of
business
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes the senator Marjory
Mr Speaker if I know
that
I am part of one of the largest
deliberative bodies
in the western world and that this body
has consistently respected the
desire to have as many people as
possible
participate in the legislative process
and if I know that attendance at the end
of the day tomorrow
will be lower than it is now would I as
a courtesy support this amendment and
vote to permit the bill to be heard now
thank you
chair recognized representative Osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
speaker so if I do agree that timing is
everything and that grandstanding over
the outraged Azure is best saved till
the end of session when all of our other
the motion before us is through special
order 399 to the next order of business
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
sit down
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
159 voting yay 173 voting May the motion
for what reason is memorized
I Rise for a motion Mr Speaker stage of
motion
Mr Speaker I moved to take House Bill
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call voter
the motion before us is to take 1674 off
motion before us
is to take 1674 off the table it's a
I'm sorry
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry
quite all right Mr Speaker I have the
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the landscape from
women's health is about to change
drastically at a time when this body
will not be in session to do anything
about it also be in order and if I want
to make very clear my support for a
woman's right to control her own body
and her own health care decisions
what I now vote
to take House Bill
chair recognize representative Osborne
for parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you Mr Speaker if I also agree
that I would like to make my voice heard
on the issue of our bodily autonomy and
I know that I will have that opportunity
here in a few short minutes what I now
the motion before us is to take 1674 off
the table
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
158 voting yay 173 voting a
motion to remove 1674 from the table
fields
for what reason is the member rise
to make a motion stage in motion Mr
speaker I move that cacr18 be removed
the motion is non-debatable but pis are
acceptable
so the motion is to take
cic r18
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is to remove cacr18
from the table this will be a roll call
vote
chair recognizes Willow for a
speaker if I know that in November of
81 percent of New Hampshire voters added
to our constitution a right to privacy
an individual right to live free from
government intrusion in private or
personal information as being natural
essential and inherent and that this
that this does not apply to New
and if I know there is no caveat in
Article 1 that says all men are born
equally free and independent except when
pregnant and yet that loss of freedom
and Independence is exactly what happens
resulting in reproductive servitude and
if I know women and men should both be
free from government interference in
their reproductive Health Care decisions
New Hampshire men having enjoyed a
default of the government being hands
off their choices for Generations
and finally Mr Speaker if I know New
Hampshire's citizens value our natural
rights and it is unjust and undue a
burden to restrict reproductive medical
decisions would I now press the green
button to take
cacr18 off the table so our state may
begin to take action to make all of our
Reproductive Rights in violet
chair recognizes Representative Steven
Smith for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I agree with my colleague that timing
is everything and when growing up I was
taught
do your homework before you go out to
play eat your dinner before you have
your dessert then Mr Speaker would I
press the red button to stop adding
extra work while we're still in the
the motion before us is to take six
cacr18 off the table it's a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
157 voting a 174 voting a motion to
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 227 FN and act
relative to death benefits for First
Responders who die from suicide
have been considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment a
recommendation to build out a password
Amendment Senator Gerald Griffin for the
committee the amendment is 13308 printed
in house record 17 pages 55. are you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted bill on second reading open to
further Amendment
wall per floor amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
so
in a totally unrelated manner matter
matter
Amendment 1915 which is in your seat
Pockets with my name on it
will attach the language of house bill
1101.
which dealt with acid forfeiture
and what came out of the committee with
a 17-4 strong bipartisan support
and passed this house on a Voice vote on
March 16th but the Senate has seen fit
to schedule for interim study it would
attach that language
to Senate Bill 227 just to refresh your
memory all it does is it says if this if
state law enforcement under state law
ceases
property they cannot offer that to the
federal government
to be forfeited
under federal law that's all it says
it's just a it's a loophole
for years we've been
tightening our asset forfeiture laws and
giving our citizens much better
protection than what federal law offers
and this is a little loophole and all
we're trying to do is close that
loophole
and I ask you as the house has done in
foreign
motion before us is the wall per floor
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the wall per floor amendment is adopted
a motion before us now is ought to pass
as amended on Senate Bill 227 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
opposed nay
and eyes have it and the committee
the committee on finance to which was
referred as the 267 FNA an act
establishing the Upland invasive species
program program fund and program
coordinator in the Department of
Agriculture markets and food having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment
representative Gerald Griffin for the
committee
the amendment number is
17798 printed in-house record page 17
pages
58.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the committee
report of ought to pass as amended are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the committee on finance to which was
referred SB 275 an act relative to the
opioid abatement trust fund having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Representative Keith
ER for the committee the amendment
number is one eight three one-h printed
in house record 17 Pages 59 through 60.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the question now is on the
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended on SB 275 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the committee on finance to which was
relative to the reimbursement of
Sheriff's offices for prisoner custody
and control having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Gerald Griffin for the
committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the committee on finance to which was
referred SB 346 FNA an act requiring the
Department of Environmental Services to
conduct feasibility and impact studies
for the construction of a Pierre on
Hampton Beach having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
Representative Bob Lin for the committee
the amendment number is one eight three
zero H printed in house record 17 Pages
71 to 72. are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question now is on ought to
pass as amended on SB 346 FNA are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
okay all right the majority of the
committee on finance to which was
referred SB 366 FN an act requiring an
audit of ballots cast in the 2022
primary and general election having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass representative Maureen Mooney for
the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee on finance
to which was referred SB 366fn and act
or twice required oh having considered
the same and being unable to agree with
the majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative William
representative hatch
is recognized to speak
thank you madam
whoa
try again is that good thank you madam
speaker
Ben thank you fellow members
Senate Bill 366 has the stated purpose
of increasing both her confidence in the
general election count by directing the
Secretary of State to audit
plus or minus one percent of the votes
placed utilizing acrovoked machines in
the primary and possibly the general
election
to accomplish this within the
established parameters set it would
require purchase of a high-speed counter
by the state at a cost up to one hundred
thousand dollars
no I say possibly the general election
because the bill allows a secretary of
state to forego
account audit of the general election
if he or she determines that there are
unresolved issues with the process in
the in the primary election audit
so in other words we're being asked to
please take your
take your shins outside the member has a
right to be heard
thank you thank you madam speaker too
bad you're leaving this is exciting
stuff
um and here's what the excitement is so
in other words we're being asked to
appropriate a hundred thousand dollars
to something we are not sure will work
again a hundred thousand dollars for
something we will not we're not sure it
will work as so stated in the bill now
remember if you I heard a few times
today that we were asked for a few
hundred thousand dollars for something
that was determined maybe appropriate
worthwhile but the statement was we
don't have the money
well I just found a hundred thousand
dollars for you I think
um so as structured the other issue with
it as structure the very small number of
machines that will be audited will do
little to instill confidence in the
voter count
um again less than one percent of
machines utilized will be audited at a
cost of a hundred thousand dollars and
again we're not sure it will work or it
will be adequate so for the reasons I
stated in others I ask you this please
vote no on the out to pass motion so
that we may bring forward another motion
thank you madam speaker and fellow
members
the chair recognizes representative
Mundy to speak in favor of the committee
report
thank you madam speaker and members of
the house I rise on behalf of the
majority of the finance committee to
support the motion of ought to pass on
Senate bill
366. in challenging times with various
opinions and thoughts surrounding
election integrity and voter confidence
the house election law committee
unanimously endorsed
as did this Full House on the consent
calendar the idea of testing voting
machine accuracy this fall
the bill authorizes the Secretary of
State to audit all accu-vote devices in
at least
two voting districts in the 2022 State
primary election
Additionally the Secretary of State can
then randomly audit accu-vote devices in
not less than four voting districts in
the 2022 general election unless
foregone due to unresolved problems
detected in the primary
now to perform these audits the purchase
of a high-speed scanner is required the
scanner cost to the state is between 50
to 100
000 and the majority of the finance
committee found this expense reasonable
to test machine accuracy and increase
more voter confidence this expense is
far from the phrase a waste of money
please press the green button to ensure
these audits take place this fall as the
Full House intended them to on the
consent calendar just last month thank
you madam speaker and thank you members
for your attention does the member yield
to questions
thank you for taking my question
representative Mooney would you believe
that in the state of New Hampshire
over three million dollars a year is
spent on auditing our money on Bank
audits
and would you also believe that in the
course of the same year there's no
regular budgeted amount to audit our
votes
for the question representative I do
believe
representative walls has requested a
division vote members will take their
seats
idea
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
that is sufficiently second and members
space
this will be a roll call Boat members
the house will be in order
thank you
representative walls is recognized for a
thank you madam speaker
if I know that there are 308 polling
locations across New Hampshire and that
auditing less than one percent of the
machines used in an election is
insufficient to find fraud or to enhance
voter confidence
if I know that after every election
there are days of recounts that can find
fraud if it exists but so far have
failed to find any fraud in voting
machines or elsewhere
if I know that these Scanning Machines
cannot be used for any recode recounts
for none of the recounts Because by
Statute recounts must be done by hand
and if I know that this came to the
finance committee to determine whether
this is a wise use of a hundred thousand
dollars
and if I know that a hundred thousand
dollars is a lot of money to spend on a
machine that will be used only for six
audits every two years
looking for fraud that has never been
seen in New Hampshire
then when I now press the red button so
that an alternative motion can be made
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
Griffin
her parliamentary inquiry thank you
madam speaker if I know that performing
checks on election results is crucial to
having confidence in our election
results and this process was already
approved by this body
and if I know that this in a previous
session we have now in statute a statute
authorizing the testing of high-speed
scanners to explore the auditing of
election results and that testing has
occurred successfully so we know it will
work and the scanners will be available
for future use and if I know that this
process steps sets in place the next
steps for performing audits on elections
by directing the Secretary of State to
test the voting machine accuracy for
elections this year and in September in
November something our constituents want
and we can use for future legislation
would I now press the green button to
support the unanimous recommendations of
both the election law committee and the
finance committee thank you excuse me I
apologize the finance committee was not
unanimous I was apparently wishing thank
you
the question is on the committee report
of ought to pass for SB 366. this is a
roll call vote if you are in favor you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
177 in the affirmative 139 in the
the committee on finance to which was
referred SB 371 FNA an act making an
appropriation to the lead paint Hazard
remediation fund having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Gerald Griffin for
the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
oh thank you
the committee on finance to which Rosa
bird SB
376fn enact relative to creating a board
to review police incidents involving
citizens affected by mental health
issues having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass the amendment number is
17288 printed in house record 7 page 77
are you ready for the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
are those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the question now is on the
committee report of ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
the eyes haven't and the committee
oh my goodness
okay
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred SB 381 FNA an act
establishing an office of the advocate
for special education having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representing Mary Jane walner
for the minority of the committee
the amendment number is one eight five
seven eight printed in-house record 17
the chair recognizes representative
the amendment to Senate Bill 381 was
likely developed to separate out the
duplicate efforts of the office of the
child advocate and the newly suggested
advocate for special education
the house education committee heard
quite a bit of testimony regarding the
fact that ensuring the right to adequate
and appropriate health care and
education is already under the oversight
of the child Advocates office
there was considerable discussion about
adding Personnel to that office
specifically designated to handle
Special Education cases Personnel who
could execute the charges put forth by
Senate Bill 381 and do it at a
significantly reduced cost
but rather than amending SB 381 to
develop a special education Advocate
position within the office of the child
1857 H seeks to remove the authority of
the child advocate
to have access to any educational
records at all
the amendment would strike the word
education from RSA 21v
in both the job description and the
section granting access to records and
Facilities as needed to the child
advocate
there's a large oversight in this
amendment
Senate Bill 381 attempts to create an
advocate's position for children with
disabilities
students specifically mentioned within
the bill only include those who receive
special education services via an
individualized education program or a
Section 504 plan
children without disabilities are not
covered
so what happens if the office of the
child advocate is investigating a case
that involves a child who does not have
a disability
what if dcyf has custody or the Juvenile
Justice System
if this amendment passes the child
advocate's office would have no access
to Student Records to school Personnel
to evaluations reports or any other
information currently considered part of
their right to an education
how then is the adequate and appropriate
education being guaranteed
this oversight is huge
including educational access
to the child to RSA 21v was most
definitely intentional when it happened
removing it would be a colossal
unintended consequence
that could tie the hands of the very
people we count on to protect our most
vulnerable kids and leave those kids
standing In Harm's Way
who is their advocate
please vote no on the amendment by
pushing the red button thank you
the chair recognizes the member from
topden Borough representative cordelli
to speak in favor of the amendment
thank you madam speaker
this bill establishes an independent
independent Office of the advocate for
special education
the minority believes that this the
functions in this bill should instead be
placed on the current office of child
advocate
the office of child advocate director
came before us and said that they have
authority over the Department of
Education
funny I thought the governor did but
that's just me
um the debatable point here is whether
they have authority over the Department
the bill
the debatable point is here is whether
they have authority over the Department
of Education
the statute covering the child advocate
mentions State departments state
government departments but
specifies
Health and Human Services
nothing else
the RSA also defines child as someone
quote in the custody of or receiving
services from Health and Human Services
nothing to do with kids in public
education or children with special needs
certainly nothing in the statute gives
them authority over local public school
districts and that is where special
education services are provided
Department of Education has told us they
have no involvement in Direct Services
to children
the statute for the child advocate deals
specifically with dcyf and Juvenile
Justice it would be a horrible mistake
to combine that with special education
this amendment
clarifies and puts in unequivocable
terms that the office of child advocate
has no role in education or special
education complaints by removing only
two references to education in the child
advocate statute
two references that's it
please support the co the finance
committee Amendment and eliminate a
reason for not passing this important
the question is on the amendment number
one eight five seven H are you ready for
the question a division vote has been
please
members should be in their seats the
chair recognizes representative Tanner
thank you madam speaker
if I know these two exclusions of
Education that are caused by this
amendment is critical
to the services offered by the office of
the child advocate and if I know that
the office of the child advocate is the
current agency mandated to provide
oversight of State arranged services to
children and to promote it children's
best interests
and if I know that the access to the
information and advocacy
for our most vulnerable children
it's education is critical to the
responsibility of the office to be able
to oversee the best interests of for a
child's overall growth development and
well-being
and if I know spending additional
funding for the office of child advocate
will fund staff and resources resulting
in services for that best interest and
improve advocacy for families dealing
with special ed issues would I now vote
to defeat this amendment so that added
funding can go to the present office of
child advocate which will limit the cost
of the state eliminate duplication of
agencies and protect all our children
the chair recognizes representative Ladd
thank you very much Madam speaker
if I know numerous parents of children
with disabilities have struggled in
receiving agreed upon special education
services as stated in their children's
IEPs
and if I know the experiences of these
parents and children are real and convey
a severe problem
and Mr Mrs Mr Speaker if I know the
current office a child advocate
actively Works towards prevention child
protection
and Juvenile Justice cases but is not
prepared to take on the role of special
education
and lastly if I know the office a child
advocate has openly communicated that it
lacks the level of expertise that is
needed to address these issues
would I then support the finance
committee's amendment by pressing the
green button thank you
the question on is is on amendment
number
1857h this is a division vote if you're
in favor you will press the green button
if you are opposed you will press the
red button voting stations will be open
foreign
[Music]
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
163 in the affirmative 152 in the
question now is on no yes the question
now is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended the chair recognizes
representative woodcock
good afternoon Madam secret thank you
ladies gentlemen like many of you here
in this room I do a lot of motorcycle
riding I've ridden in 48 of the 50
states and I make annual soldiers to New
Hampshire to California
but I do get lost
more often than I like to admit but
that's part of the adventure actually
it's more frustrating than Adventure
I was told several years ago you should
get rid of that flip phone and get an
iPhone
that'll solve your problems it can get
you directions show you where you are
talk you through the root sounded like
an easy solution just go
to the store get a new phone so I did
with a little training I learned how to
program an app on my cell phone I felt
great no more frustration of getting
lost missing exits going in the wrong
direction you get my point
problem solved I'm a happy guy
frustrations and anger subsided and then
about the memories
can I ask you what this has to do with
the bill in one paragraph you will I'll
be right there I'm getting there okay
trying to make some context here
then we also get confused thank you
he'll get there okay
I'm a happy guy frustrations in Anger
have survived and then about three hours
into the trip the map app had used all
the battery life and I was now without a
cell phone emergency access the
directions now I was really ticked off
actually I felt worse than I did before
I ever started using the phone I should
have known there was a catch
come to find out this One-Stop solution
cost me more money than I wanted to
spend really only scratched the surface
of my problems and made me feel better
but only for a short time
I was right back to where I started
angry all over again and more frustrated
a waste of time effort and money
I just felt like I want a never-ending
convey about going round and round
fast forward to 2020.
just last week actually I'm still
battling the same old problem of
inaccurate directions missed exits wrong
turns and lost
this members that will suspend stay your
representative boycott can you step back
no no no don't walk in front I don't
Madam speaker this has little to do with
the bill and even though there was
conversation about this just a couple of
minutes ago it seems to be going on
your point is well taken and I trust the
speaker has finished that paragraph
yes I am now Madam speaker absolutely
thank you very much
so I'll pass I'll go past Tuesday
afternoon it was a disaster anyhow
my friends the story is true even the
part you didn't hear and it does
actually relate to SB 381 because the
proposal of an independent Advocate and
I quote directly from the bill serves as
a resource for information ensures all
IAP plans are documented reviews all
documents has access to IAP 504s and
shoes proper documentation tracks
metrics disagreements complaints of
parents and caretakers implements and
measures and tracks and gives parents
the insurance that five days in advance
for me to be notified
The Advocate
in 381 shall prepare a detailed report
for the governor the Speaker of the
House the president of the Senate
Etc
nowhere in this bill
portion is designed to connect nowhere
in the bill is an independent Advocate
given legal authority to change anything
imagine that you are an angry parent of
a special ed student you have in your
mind the belief that the school is not
meeting your child's educational needs
you've had a meeting after meeting with
teachers and guidance counselors sped
administrators you've gone over the IEP
you've modified the IOP you bet over
backwards to get help from the school
district your child and still no success
nothing has changed
then you hear about this new position
sort of like a new cell phone a new
Office Independent Advocate who is not
connected to the school or to the State
education department and their role is
to serve as the point of contact for you
finally you think the solution is close
at hand
you meet The Advocate and one of the
assistants and you go through your
entire Litany of years of disappointment
with the school lack of services
insufficient time too much paperwork
with little or no resolve you are
praying that this now that's frustration
and ordeal may be over and finally
someone has heard your needs and your
child can get the services you've been
asking for for way too long no no no
the independent Advocate who is not
connected with the school district or
the state doe has no power or authority
to change one phrase one Activity one
set of services in the IEP agreement for
your child this department like my phone
on the motorcycle is not connected
this new unnecessary five hundred
thousand dollar office cannot solve the
parents problem the parent has month
once again met with the system's failure
this is not a win for the parent or the
child
this feel-good option may sound good and
terrific and look good but it doesn't
get the job done it doesn't even pass
the smell test
I understand the intent of the bill
parents need options
the voices need to be heard and there
has to be a map to get them in the right
exit
in this case the directions are clear
the root is already set and the phone is
charged the doe within their current
special ed options already has the
process for parents to be hurried the
doe already has individuals assigned to
help parents with child IEPs and will
serve as their Advocates the doe already
has a process in place and an
independent investigator to review
complaints from parents for lack of
service of the child and it has the
legal authority to direct action to
correct inequities and violations of law
the doe already has a due process
hearing program and many other services
for parents
all these services and programmatic
options that a parent needs to have and
they're concerned examined are already
in place they are already connected to
the DOE
the answer to reducing the parent
frustration and proving the piles
options is not accompanied by creating
another level of costly ineffective
powerless reporting writing bureaucracy
but rather perhaps a simple plan as
training by Doe to have their programs
better understood and more easily
accessible by parents
please vote right on SB 381 it was not
just the money that would be one thing
but the Bill's problems were far beyond
the dollar signs thank you madam speaker
the chair recognizes the member from
Tuftonboro representative cordelli to
speak in favor of the report
thank you madam speaker and I will talk
about the bill
this bill establishes an independent
office of advocate for special education
and as we said before
independent is the key this office and
the director will not be linked to any
local school district or the Department
of Education and that's important
they will have the responsibility to
take complaints from parents and to
investigate those compare those
complaints and put pressure on districts
when necessary they'll be able to
examine IEP records track meeting
results and even have parents complete
evaluation reports on their IEP meetings
this office will annually report back to
us on their findings
as a result of a study committee last
fall
this bill grew out of discussions after
the study committee
also another outcome is that there will
be a performance audit done on special
education at the Department of Education
the Senate passed SB 381 on the consent
calendar with leadership of both parties
as co-sponsors
but unfortunately it's not a bipartisan
the director
of the current office
said that they were not prepared to deal
with special education and that is a
reason that you helped us in passing the
amendment just now the committee
Amendment
the testimony we heard from the special
education administrators Association
stated that there is no evidence that
the process is flawed
well tell that to parents
a survey of parents last spring showed
that 30 percent of parents of children
with disabilities felt that they were
not an equal partner in determining the
services that their child would receive
40 percent indicated that they were
never asked about if the services were
meeting their child's needs
we heard the argument that there was a
cost to this new office and that is
growing government
it's a relatively small small cost but
what about the human cost
what about future government costs when
these children cannot get the services
they need and become adults depending on
Government Services rather independent
adults out in the community
I wish you could have been there to hear
the hearings we had and heard from the
parents parents in tears
stories from parents who have had to
take out second mortgages
parents who have gone bankrupt trying to
get services for their child all while
trying to get a free free public
education for their child
stories of pressure intimidation
retaliation yes retaliation for trying
to get help for their children
we even had testimony from one parent
who went to court for protection from
threats
we heard from parents who are lawyers
parents who are former State reps former
state senators
yet the Department of Education will
tell you that they only get about 30
complaints a year
well maybe there's a reason they only
get 30 complaints a year
for way too many parents the system is
broken that is why we need the office of
advocate for special education why they
need this office
I think our new guiding principle for
Education should be be bold be impatient
impatient yes our children are only
young once
parents especially those in special
education have been patient for way too
long
impatient
patient for improvements patient for new
parent manuals parent training
parents are tired of waiting when their
child's future is at stake parents will
no longer wait to be listened to they
will no longer be wait to be patient and
neither should we
that patient ends now
give these kids a chance
press green and Mr Speaker
the question is on SB 381 the majority
committee report of ought to pass is
amended representative cordelli has
requested a roll call vote is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
yesterday
foreign
the question is on the majority
committee report for SB 381 this is a
roll call vote if you are in favor you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button oh
but I'm going to recognize
representative luno for a parliamentary
thank you thank you very much Madam
speaker if I know this bill does nothing
to enhance the dispute resolution
process already in place at the
Department of Education that addressed
the 30-ish complaints the department
received last year and doesn't cost a
half a million bucks to do it and if I
know the bill is amended strips the
office of child advocate of any
responsibility to ensure children in the
state's care
and this includes foster children are
receiving an adequate and appropriate
education fundamental to their
well-being
then would I press the red button so
that we can move forward with the motion
that was recommended by finance division
the Vlad for parliamentary inquiry
thank you very much Madam speaker
if I know this Bill had strong testimony
from parents
with 65 parents signed in support of the
bill
and five in opposition primarily
representing the system
and if I know this bill envisions a new
independent office to work with parents
with the sole purpose to ensure the
school districts are in compliance with
the state required individualized
education programs that we offer
students
and if I further know this bill will
help press schools to honor their
obligations
under the federal individual I
individuals with Disabilities Act
to educate students and provide special
education services as required in IEPs
that are written contracts with parents
would I then support this legislation
which is a valuable and viable
independent solution that better
supports parents and the needs of
children by pressing the green button
thank you very much Madam speaker
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you will press the green button if
you are opposed you will press the red
button boating stations are open for 30
seconds
years
sometimes
have all members president had the
opportunity to vote the house will
170 in the affirmative 155 in the
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 394 FN enact
relative to the definition of a child
with a disability under special
education laws in establishing a
commission to study special education
eligibility having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation to Bill or
password Amendment Senator Mary Heath
for the committee amendment is 17708
printed in house record 17 page 81 the
questions on the amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted
motion before us now is ought to pass
with Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on financing which was
referred Senate Bill 401 FN enact making
Appropriations to the Department of
Transportation for local Highway Aid in
the body worn and dashboard camera fund
and permitting the Department of
Transportation to operate dash cameras
fleet vehicles have been considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Karen umberger for the
committee the majority amendment is one
eight four four-h printed in house
record 17 Pages 88 89. are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it in
the committee amendment is adopted bills
on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative turcard office floor
amendment 19278 in your seat pockets
and is recognized to speak to his
Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
this floor Amendment passed this body as
HP 1337 just a little while ago
with near unanimous support from our
Republican caucus only three were
against
this amendment would index the number of
weeks an individual could collect
unemployment compensation to the current
unemployment rate in New Hampshire
the maximum number of weeks would remain
at 26 which is what it is today
many states have already adopted similar
legislation and the results are
Universal businesses the ones who fund
our Unemployment Insurance Fund see a
reduction in the employees unemployment
insurance tax rate
and the unemployed individuals look for
and go back to work more quickly
the legislation also contains language
that would allow the governor in times
of emergency like we witnessed in the
2008 financial crisis and the recent
covet epidemic to override this RSA
I ask that you press the green button to
support the motion of ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition to Amendment 1927 h
as it was stated this amendment is the
former HB 1337.
that bill and this Amendment provide a
solution to a problem that does not
exist
this amendment reduces the unemployment
payment duration during times of low
unemployment
he will be argued or it has been argued
that this limitation will provide an
incentive for unemployed workers to get
back to work
sounds reasonable however
as I already stated
this incentive is not needed
the Department of Labor Deputy
Commissioner testified that New
Hampshire has lower unemployment
this meager unemployment payment level
is incentive enough for people to get
back to work
as soon as they can
this the Deputy Commissioner further
testified
that indeed very few people take the
so what harm will do will it do to
reduce the duration of benefits
actually this amendment will do real
harm to some of the unemployed people
if a person has physical limitations
extraordinary family obligations or
other different life circumstances
the full 26 weeks of benefit may be
needed
because of these life circumstances and
it would make it very difficult to find
a new job
this is all in independent and separate
from the unemployment rate
this unnecessary incentive should be
rejected to avoid the hardship it will
cause to a small number of unemployed
New Hampshire workers
please press the red button to reject
this unnecessary Amendment and Mr
a division has been requested members
take your seats
well
roll call has been requested by
representative Noonan is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the turcotte
floor Amendment
this is going to be a roll call vote
Jay I recognizes representative Osborne
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr speaker so if I know that
tying the length of unemployment
benefits to the rate of unemployment has
been done in other states and is a
common sense way of reducing
unemployment taxes paid by businesses
and incentivizing workers to get back
into the workforce where they are
desperately needed and I know that this
language and this amendment has already
passed this body decisively a number of
weeks ago would I now press the green
button and reaffirm the house position
chair recognized representative Sullivan
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that other states that may
have adopted this provision have
substantially higher unemployment
payment levels New Hampshire does
therefore might need a greater incentive
and if I know that this
Amendment for that reason is entirely
unnecessary
and finally if I know that this
amendment
if it becomes law
will do real harm to the small number of
unemployed people who truly depend on 26
weeks of unemployment because of
difficulties that they have in finding
new employment
Mr Speaker would I then press the red
button to defeat this amendment thank
you motion before us is a turquot floor
Amendment this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your oppose you'll press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
173 voting a 142 voting a circuit floor
Amendment passes
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended chair recognizes Senator
Bert to speak against the committee
report
I have a problem with Senate Bill 401
and let me I've already told you guys
what it was and I didn't do very well
last time
so I'm hoping my vote will
be a little better this time
why I don't like this one car in Senate
Bill 401
is the dot dash cams
I understand the theory behind it
and I support it
but the dash cam
video will be stored for three days
it is to be deleted
so when I asked the question in the
committee I said so can somebody come in
in that three days and grab that video
and store it on their little thumb drive
and the guy goes well absolutely they
can
and then he says we can use it for
training or anything else we want to use
it for
I was happy to hear today when my
friend from stratum got up here
and she spoke about that Constitutional
Amendment that we passed
the one where passed overwhelmingly in
the state of New Hampshire saying that
we want to be private
in our lives
and sadly Mr Speaker this one part of
so Mr Speaker lastly
Senate bill
401 has a lot of taxes in it
and Mr Speaker
taxation is theft
chair recognizes representative umberger
SP 401 touches every single community in
our state
it provides money for Bridges and for
roads
million
no that's the wrong number 66 million
dollars
that's a lot of cash to go towards roads
and bridges
this money is
um
not being raised through taxes
I'm not exactly sure where that came
from
when we first got the bill
it said that all the money for that was
allocated for Bridges
had to go to red listed Bridges
well that was kind of an ugly thing
because every Community would have to
raise 20 percent match
in order to get any of this bridge money
and we thought that was a really bad
idea
especially since
through the infrastructure program
dot is going to have lots of
red listed Bridge money to hand out but
we wanted all the bridges in the
community whether they were red listed
or just had huge potholes
also there are dollars that will be
going out for
um
body cameras
for uh we have a a program already for
uh body cameras for our local police and
we will be adding money to that
now I realize
that there is some concern
about the dash cameras
when they when
when dot came to talk to us about this
they brought us several pictures
where
motorists
have smashed into their vehicles
and the problem is that sometimes it's
only a side swipe
and the car is not disabled or the truck
and so this car or truck just goes
Merrily on its way
and we
the taxpayers get stuck with repairing
that particular vehicle
I think we all maybe had seen the other
night where a uh a Volkswagen ran into
the back of a
of a truck
and fortunately
that vehicle didn't go any place after
it hit
because it was really smashed
but
I can assure you from the people that I
talk to
that this information is going to be
used
in order to find the offenders
that have run into
dots vehicles and that's its major major
purpose
yes we can all have theories about
the Goblins coming in and getting the
getting the downloads but
please I think we can trust
our state workers not to allow that to
happen
so I thank you and um bridge and Road
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on Senate bill 401.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
committee on finance to us was deferred
Senate Bill 407 FN
back relative to expanding
an act relative to expanding Medicaid to
include extra postpartum Health Care
Services in making an appropriation
therefore consider the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass
enger Keith for the committee
Bill's open once to Second reading open
to further Amendment representative
turcott office floor Amendment 1926 h
chair recognizes representative turcotte
to speak to his Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker I'm here to introduce floor
Amendment
2022-1926-h which would require any
public employer any private employer
that receives any form of public tax
dollars and post-secondary educational
institution to offer to their employees
an exemption from intrusive vaccination
mandates and inoculations
no employee should have to choose
between a forced injection and the loss
of their job and no employer should be
forced to impose a mandate on their
employees this body recently passed this
exact leg legislation with bipartisan
support as well as near unanimous
I ask that you please press the green
button so that we can once again protect
the rights of New Hampshire's employers
and their employees thank you Mr Speaker
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to speak against the floor
amendment to SB 407.
it inserts language from hb1210 into an
important bill which extends the
postpartum Medicaid coverage from 60
days to 12 months for a small group of
mothers on Medicaid who earn between 138
and 196 percent of the federal poverty
level
the amendment allows exemptions
from any employer mandate for any
vaccine instituted by any private or
public employer who receives any federal
or state funds on the basis of a medical
exemption
without any documentation
a religious exemption without any
documentation
or explanation or a simple conscientious
objection
this makes any mandate useless
there are several problems with this
amendment first the amendment tells
businesses how to run their businesses
not good
secondly the amendment is in conflict
with the rules promulgated by CMS with
regard to covid-19 vaccination mandate
which requires documentation of the
medical reason for the medical exemption
signed by a licensed practitioner
documentation of religious exemptions
and it does not
allow conscientious objection as an
exemption this will place our facilities
out of compliance with CMS
and it'll be therefore at risk of civil
penalties loss of reimbursement for
Medicare and Medicaid patients and
ultimately termination from Medicare and
Medicaid participation
and I need to remind you that Medicaid
pays the bill for two-thirds of our
nursing home residents
the state of New Hampshire and your
county delegations would then need to
backfill that Revenue loss in order to
keep these facilities open and that's
starting with just that 200 million
dollars which is the federal share of
Medicaid funding for long-term care in
New Hampshire alone and it's like real
money this is going to raise the
property taxes in all of our counties
and the cost will be vastly more when
the Medicare reimbursement for hospital
care is also included
some have claimed that CMS will not stop
reimbursement as it has not happened in
other states that have placed similar
laws in place but that's not a guarantee
the mandate's relatively new and
enforcement actions are only commencing
now and CMS has already sanctioned the
state of Kansas for a similar bill
the U.S Supreme Court ruling on January
13 of 2022 upheld the CMS mandate
for vaccination of health care workers
staying the lower court injunction in
the text of the Supreme Court decision
makes it clear that if the lower court
decision ultimately makes it to the
Supreme Court on appeal that they will
uphold the mandate
and to date
no appeal of the lower court injunction
has been filed
the point is that vaccine mandates in a
health care setting is crucial
since hospitals and long-term care
facilities care for vulnerable
individuals they must do everything they
can to maintain safety that includes a
reasonable expectation of a patient
or a resident to not face unnecessary
exposure to an infectious disease from
the health care worker caring for them
and remember this isn't just about covid
this is for any vaccination whether it
be flu or anything
this bill then this actually brings us
to one more problem this bill is coached
as protecting your Liberty but it's
actually against Liberty
and this was just pointed out very well
just last week in an article about
hb1210 by Andrew Klein of the Josiah
Bartlett Center for Public Policy not
exactly a left-wing organization
Klein wrote quote vaccination status is
not an immutable characteristic like
race or sex it is a choice
and not a purely individualistic one
it can have profound even life or death
consequences for others
framed as a defense of individual
liberty the bill would actually reduce
Liberty if enacted it would weaken the
right of free individuals to associate
only with others who accept their
dedication to fighting infectious
diseases through vaccination
end quote
Klein points out that people have a
right to associate with others who
choose to vaccinate this amendment will
violate that right of Association
here's a real world example let's say
Your mother wishes to be placed in a
nursing home or she chooses a nursing
home in which vaccinations are mandated
for her safety
that is her right of Association
she may have chosen that nursing home
for that very reason
but if this amendment becomes law
her right of Association is violated
and her bodily Integrity may be violated
by a virus that she does not wish to be
violated by
so protect your mother
protect our businesses and protect our
Medicare and Medicaid funding by
pressing the red button to defeat the
motion to amend SB 407 with this
amendment and I ask for a division vote
please
remember yield to questions
does memory yield to questions
the motion before artists the terracotte
floor Amendment a division has been
requested members take your seats
roll call has been requested by Senator
Byrd is that sufficiently it is
sufficiently secondary this will be a
foreign
house will be in order
the motion before us is the turkot floor
Amendment this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Osborne for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
language in this amendment uh has
already passed this house once before a
few weeks ago if I know that no employer
should be required to threaten their
employees jobs over uh Federal mandates
and if I know no employee should have to
choose between their employment and a
forced penetration
would I now press the green button and
that's hard to follow
but
Mr Speaker if I know that this has
nothing to do with forcing
businesses to have a mandate in fact it
prohibits them
from placing a mandate
so I know if I know that this amendment
will wrongly tell our businesses how to
run their business
and if I know that this amendment will
put us in out of compliance with respect
to the CMS vaccine mandate resulting in
potentially a massive loss of Medicare
and Medicaid funding and therefore
raising your taxes explain that to your
voters and if I know that this amendment
will endanger
our patients and our nursing home
residents and if I know that this
amendment removes the right of
association with those who support the
control of infectious disease with
immunization
[Music]
and if I want to protect
our patients your mother in the nursing
home our businesses and protect our
Medicare and Medicaid funding would I
then press the red button to vote no to
defeat the motion to amend 407 with this
amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is the turcotte floor
Amendment
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press green
if you're opposed you'll press red
[Music]
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
162 voting a 153 voting a
turkot floor amendment is adopted
motion before us now was
ought to pass as amended on Senate bill
407.
a division has been requested were
requested or division has been requested
so be at the
roll call has been requested by
represent a blazik is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
yes
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on Senate bill 407.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposed will press the red button
open
Instagram
[Music]
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
under a 95 voting a 28 voting May
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 412 FNA that making
an appropriation to the Department of
Health and Human Services for nursing
home reimbursement rates considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation Bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative just
Edwards for the committee the amendment
is 1582h printed in house record 17 Page
90. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
as opposed me
you always have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 1416 FN act
relative to behavioral health assessment
and treatment for children in in and out
of home placements having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation to fill out a
password Amendment representative Mary
Jane waller for the committee the
amendment is 1786 age printed in house
record 17 Page 90. you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
where's the postnay you always have it
the amendment is adopted the question
before us now is the motion to ought to
pass with Amendment on house on Senate
Bill 416fn are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
president Paul's name you guys have it
the committee on finance the which was
referred Senate Bill 417 FN establishing
an electric School Bus pilot program it
chair recognizes Representative Steven
Smith
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to lay a
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the lay Senate Bill 417 on
the table
Mission the vision has been requested
the motion before racist the motion to
lay on the table on Senate Bill 417 FN
chair recognizes representative Smith
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill sets up a very specific path for
electric School Bus pilot programs and
Mr Speaker if I know that there are
already other paths available that
districts and municipalities even are
free to pursue federal grants and seek
those benefits then would I press the
green button to table this bill
recognize your representative Heath for
is about authorization to accept funds
from the New Hampshire Volkswagen
mitigation trust funds and if I further
know this would be a wonderful program
for students what I know
vote no on the tabling motion thank you
very much Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 417 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your post you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
166 voting yay 151 voting a Senate Bill
majority of the committee on finance the
the noise level is getting way too loud
connect relative to verification of
voter affidavits having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Gerald Griffin from the majority
of the committee the amendment is 18708
printed in-house record 17 Pages 90 and
91. you're ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the committee
amendment is adopted the chair
recognizes representative Waltz speak
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is an example of a solution
looking for a problem and then creating
a very expensive unintended consequence
despite the Secretary of State having a
full-time lawyer on staff to find and
investigate fraud and voter
registrations fraud has not been found
there is absolutely no evidence of
people registering under a false
identity here in New Hampshire
let me repeat that there is no evidence
of people registering under a false
identity here in New Hampshire
to address a problem that's never been
found to exist
this bill creates provisional ballots
that are marked to identify the voter
casting the ballot
those ballots are then set aside and
counted separately
seven days later if the voter has not
gone back and provided the requested
identification the ballots may be
identified as being cast by specific
voters and uncounted
this means that elections cannot be
certified until a week after the polls
close
as drafted this bill will place New
Hampshire in violation of two federal
laws and violate our own state
constitution
please let me explain
first under the uniformed and overseas
citizens absentee Voting Act or yokava
as is usually known ballots must be
mailed 45 days before the general
election
with our late primary a delay in the
certification of the primary election
results means the secretary of state
will not have sufficient time to print
and mail the ballots to overseas voters
within the requisite 45 days
this means that members of our military
stationed overseas
government employees working overseas
or other American citizens living
overseas may not receive their ballots
in time to be able to return them
quickly enough to be counted on Election
Day
hence the delay will put us both out of
compliance with yokava and may
disenfranchise overseas voters including
our members of the military stationed
overseas
second New Hampshire enjoys an exemption
from the national voter registration act
sometimes called Motor Voter
we have that exemption because our same
day registration procedures
this new requirement effectively
eliminates the same day registration for
certain voters thereby placing us out of
compliance with the ACT
if we are found not to be in compliance
we could be forced to completely change
our voter registration procedures at an
estimated cost of 6.5 million dollars
all of this to stop fraud that's never
been found
third perhaps the most egregious
unintended consequences of the bill is
that it creates violations of our own
state constitution
the Constitution guarantees our right to
a secret ballot
for those who have their ballots marked
with an identifying label their ballots
are no longer Secret
any voting official can see the ballot
and who cast it
furthermore
subtracting votes after the tally is
made election night is a violation of
part two article 32 of the Constitution
no doubt someone will sue the state over
the last time we passed a law to stop
this kind of non-existent voter fraud
sb3 it cost the state 4.2 million
dollars in legal fees as well as the
cost of two full-time lawyers for a year
in the Department of Justice
do we really want to face this kind of
legal expense again
this bill as a classic example of a bill
that has very expensive unintended
consequences it violates two federal
laws it could cost taxpayers millions of
dollars to restructure our voter
registration system
it violates two provisions of our New
Hampshire Constitution that could cost
us Millions to try and defend the
indefensible
all of this to try and stop fraud that
has never been found anywhere in New
Hampshire
please join me in voting no on this
deeply flawed bill so member yield the
GI recognizes representative Barbara
Griffin
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of SB 418 as amended
by the finance committee the amended we
just passed dealed with dealt with a
technical deficiency that was found in
regards to the processing and we've all
agreed as to the bill being amended to
address that I would point out that the
affidavit process that you just heard
about has already been approved by this
body
and it ensures that everyone who comes
to the polling place on Election Day
will be able to cast a ballot and it
also ensures that all votes counted will
be those cast by persons who can be
identified you've heard many times at
this well and you know yourself from
observation on Election Day in New
Hampshire anyone can vote regardless of
their ability to prove who they are how
old they are whether they're a citizen
and where they're domiciled
it is well established in court cases
across the country that requiring
identification is a reasonable
requirement in regards to protecting
State interests in running elections the
issue here in New Hampshire is that our
affidavit process has people voting and
we have no idea who they are
the process leaves us unable to verify
them you've heard that this last
election there were hundreds of people
who voted without any identification and
and so you may hear there's no
prosecution in regards to voting
for failure to have an ID but we can't
identify who we would be prosecuting
this seeks to solve that issue
those individuals who register to vote
on Election Day were only talking about
election day registration who do not
establish their ID within seven days
will have their vote withdrawn from the
vote total they still get to vote it's
counted it's held there is no violation
of federal law you heard again today
about the potential of a vote count
adverse impact on our overseas military
voters
the Secretary of State's office has been
contacted in regards to this issue and
has responded that they can make it work
and will meet the deadlines that are
necessary for the overseas voters we
have members on our committee who are
military veterans I myself have a
deceased brother who was a army vet a
hundred percent disabled who did a
lifetime service and served overseas
many times no one on our committee would
ever do anything to impair the ability
of people to meet to meet their
constitutional Duty or right to vote
the reality is ballots are not prepared
magically the day after election ballots
need to be prepared for multiple
jurisdictions with multiple variations
and the process for printing them is not
a day or two the Secretary of State's
office can identify the jurisdictions
that have persons who voted without an
ID and registered on Election Day end
where the number of affidavits might
affect the vote total right if the if
the margin a vote for your winners was
10 and there were only two two persons
who voted without an ID then clearly the
use of the affidavit ID would have no
in regards to the issues of a secret
ballot I would point out and and invite
you to observe the processing of
absentee ballots
absentee ballots are tracked through the
system so detailed that you can get
online to track your absentee ballot
which is matched with your signature in
regards to what you submit and the
envelope and then taken by a third party
who has is handed the ballot from your
affidavit envelope who goes to The
Ballot Box
the moderator in this process sees
ballots on a regular basis and your
privacy rights are still protected as
they are now
this process is a reasonable step
towards ensuring that votes cast in our
elections are cast by persons who we can
identify
the finance committee remember we're
here for the finance committee found
that the dollars associated with this
were appropriate and I ask that you
support the recommendation that came to
you from the election law committee and
now the finance committee thank you Mr
Speaker there's a member of yield the
questions no I do not member does not
yield
the motion before us is the majority
report of what to pass is amended on
Senate bill 418.
division has been requested members take
their seats
roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
members will be in their seats
the motion before us of the majority
committed a report of water passes
amended on Senate Bill 418 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Bergeron for
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that during Senate testimony
the Secretary of State expressed concern
about the Privacy issue associated with
matching ballots with specific voter
names and further suggested that the
Senate asked the Supreme Court to
respond to questions about whether or
not a vote can be removed or not counted
after the return of votes have been
filed but the Senate refused to do so
and if I know that there are less than
60 days between the conclusion of the
state primary recount period and the
date of the state general election
and that Federal Law requires that
absentee ballots be available to
Uniformed and overseas citizens at least
45 days prior to the general election
and if I know that this bill requires
towns to submit a report of provisional
ballots cast 14 days after the state
primary and that the deadline for
requests for recounts must be extended
to allow for submission of these
materials thus making it impossible to
fully comply with Federal requirements
the general election absentee ballots be
made available to Uniformed and overseas
citizens at least 45 days prior to the
general election
and if I know the provisions in the bill
could result in New Hampshire losing its
exemption to the National voter
registration act and that the cost to
implement Motor Voter requirements
should cost New Hampshire close to 6.5
million dollars
but I then press the red no button to
oppose the motion of ought to pass so
that a subsequent motion can be
presented thank you I recognize
representative Emrick for a
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill is a tempest in
a teapot based on the numbers which we
look at in finance and if I know that
the Secretary of State indicated that
approxim a number of ballots were
talking about at the last election was
733 who were affidavit ballots and of
those they estimated maybe 200 were
first-time register registrants then
we're talking about 200 first-time
registrants at 308 voting places in the
state this is not a significant number
and I think it's very manageable to have
good elections please vote green thank
you Mr Speaker
motion before us the majority committee
report of Water Pass was amended on
Senate Bill 418 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
while members president an opportunity
to vote hopes will attend to the state
164 voting a 155 voting a the committee
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill
420fna local in Act
establishing an extraordinarily need
grant for schools and relative to
additional adequate education Grand
amounts for pupils receiving special
education services consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation to Bill
ought to pass with Amendment Senator
Cameron nunberger for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same be an unable to
agree on the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that as
inexpeding to legislators and have
Leonard turcott for the minority of the
committee
the majority amendment is 1761h printed
in-house record 17 Page 91. are you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the majority
committee amendment is adopted bills on
second reading open to further Amendment
representative turkard office floor
chair recognizes representative turcott
to speak to his Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker
a month and a half ago the House of
Representatives passed what is contained
in this floor Amendment if you believe
in equal opportunities for families to
locate and afford the best possible
education that fits their child's
learning style this legislation expands
opportunities to allow moderate income
families to qualify for an education tax
credit scholarship
scholarships for lower income families
would not be jeopardized as that
opportunity already exists within the
provisions of the program
just want to reiterate that this has
nothing to do with the education Freedom
accounts this has been in existence
since 2012.
additionally there are no changes to the
maximum dollar amounts that may be
placed into the fund
through business tax credits so there's
absolutely zero tax revenue lost to the
state please support this amendment by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognizes representative
woodcock
thank you Mr Speaker
the tax credit scholarship fund was
created to support students from
low-income families
the amendment expands the annual income
parameter from 300 percent which is
about 79 000 for a family of four to
five hundred percent which is about 138
thousand dollars annual income
currently the program has exists has a a
waiting list larger than the number of
students they served
why would the legislature want to expand
an annual income requirement
when we can't fill the list of folks who
are already low income
additionally there is nothing contained
in the legislation to require low-income
families to be granted funding
before those families with the expanded
income of the additional fifty thousand
dollars
about 45 percent of the students
currently serve meet the federal
guidelines for free reduced lunch which
also means that 55 percent are below the
lowest threshold
the HB 1298 it barely passed this house
and was sounding defeat in the other
chamber so I asked you to please vote no
on this unrelated floor Amendment so we
could pass the bill in a PLU that
improves Equitable school funding thank
you
motion before us is the two turkot floor
Amendment
are you ready for the question
division has been requested members take
representative Nunes requests the roll
calls that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the Terracotta
chair recognizes representative Osborne
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
language in this amendment has already
passed this house a few weeks ago
and that all it does is simply increase
the number of families eligible for the
children's scholarship
children's tax credit scholarship would
I now press the green button
chair recognize representative luno for
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
New Hampshire's 160 000 public school
kids perform among the best in the
country and that's what parents want
and if I know the tax credit program was
billed as a way for lower income
families to pay for private school
tuition using taxpayer dollars
and if I know some of these families are
already on a waiting list but this bill
opens the floodgates to the top 20
percent of income earners then would I
press the red button to keep the program
as it was originally intended thank you
Mr Speaker
question before us is the turquad floor
Amendment it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of the opposed you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
ball members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
171 voting yay 150 voting a
jerk on floor amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is to Auto pass
as amended
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
Rosa post nay
the eyes haven't committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on finance the
which was referred Senate Bill 422 FN
back establishing adult Dental benefit
under the State Medicaid Program
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Jess Edwards
for the majority of the committee
amendment is 1331h Britain and House
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution that is in
expedient to legislate Representative
Bob Blinn for the minority of the
committee
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is how to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
people in the room only
this is a confirmation on the vote
I was about ready to declare revision
myself because I was unsure for the
first time
so this is going to be a division vote
this is going to be a division vote
strictly
on affirming
what the vote was
this so if you're in favor you will
press the green button if you're opposed
you will press the red button voting
foreign
representative
you
know
well members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
205 voting yay 109 voting may I guess
109 yelled as loud as 205 did
committee report is adopted
committee on finance the which was
referred Senate Bill 430 FNA enact
relative to Health and Human Services
having considered the same report the
same following Amendment a
recommendation to build out a password
Amendment
Senator Keith Earth for the committee
the amendment is 1883h printed in house
record 17 Page 94 through 96. you ready
for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the committee
amendment is adopted bills on second
reading open to further Amendment
representative Edwards offers floor
Amendment 1909 H in your seat pockets
and the chair recognizes representative
Edwards to speak to his Amendment
uh thank you Mr Speaker with this
amendment does is it
reinstitutes a house bill that we passed
a few weeks ago sponsored by
representative McLean went over to the
other body and they they put it in
interim study what we're trying to do is
to indicate to the other body that this
was a serious idea what what we what
we've proposed what representative
McLean proposed was that if if there is
a Health Care Organization that's a
membership based only or receives cash
payments only that they would not be
required to accept
patients that aren't within that
particular
payer mix and there aren't any of these
in New Hampshire right now so if you've
heard that this is going to hurt our
critical care hospitals and the like
it's not true because these things don't
yet exist and are critical care
facilities and others are protected with
a 15-mile radius so that there it's a
non-competitive situation in any case so
um
a couple years ago we passed a direct
primary care bill there weren't any
direct Primary Care Providers at the
time that legislation
fertilize the ground and now we have
some direct primary care so what this is
attempting to do is to lay the ground
and fertilize it again so that we can
create another alternative in our Health
Care system if we keep doing the same
thing over and over and over again we're
going to get the same kind of broken
results one of the great benefits of
doing this if we can get some of these
direct pay payment
organizations in place then we'll start
to really know what the true costs are
if you were to go to ask prior to a
procedure exactly what they're going to
charge you for a given procedure they
can't give you a price because the payer
mixes are so complicated that they can't
get to reality so so this is an
opportunity for us to peel it back and
take a fresh look at Healthcare delivery
in New Hampshire I hope you vote in
favor of it
chair recognizes representative Leon for
speak
what this amendment would do is it would
allow hospitals to operate out of the
side of the sphere of influence of CMS
the centers for Medicaid services that's
all it does and that's enough
I've heard opponents of this bill say
that it means that hospitals won't need
to have an emergency room won't need to
have a requirement for charity charity
care
that all this changes is the requirement
for a hospital to take all payers we've
seen the power of that
right now CMS is telling us what laws we
can pass here in New Hampshire CMS is
telling us what our hospitals can and
can't do and CMS is basically telling us
what doctors and other Healthcare Heroes
we have direct pay primary care and so
there are a lot of providers who do have
an option to practice outside of this um
outside of the spirit of CMS influence
but some doctors can only work in a
hospital would you see a surgeon who
these doctors right now are forced
between continuing to practice in New
Hampshire while complying with all of
these mandates are going to some other
state that's putting up more of a fight
do we want our surgeons to move to
Florida
do we want them to just retire and stop
practicing
we have a health care shortage
we need to pass this amendment and send
this on to the Senate so we can have an
option for these surgeons who otherwise
would no longer practice in New
Hampshire to open up their own hospitals
allow them to negotiate with the payers
oh negotiate with the with the patients
because right now the payers decide what
happens
this will be small it'll be Niche we
still have the 15 Mile buffer we're not
going to allow these to open up next to
our critical access hospitals because
this doesn't change that part of the law
please pass this so that the patients
are in control when you write the check
you make the decision and you'd work
directly with your doctor thank you
thank you Mr Speaker
indeed I Rise to speak against this
amendment to SB 430 as stated this
amendment would add the wording of HB
1044 to SB 430 and as it was sent to
interim study in the Senate
now first of all contrary to what was
just said this has nothing to do with
providers individual practitioners this
has to do with facilities
facility licensing that's where this
statute resides
currently licensed health care
facilities are required to provide
services to all persons regardless of
payment
this requirement was added by the
legislature in 2016 to ensure access to
services for low-income individuals and
those covered by Medicaid
and the reason for this requirement is
really pretty straightforward Medicaid
would be useless if facilities will not
treat patients who are covered by
Medicaid
and we also have uninsured patients who
need care
and guess what
they don't just crawl away and die they
need care
they need access
this amendment would exempt from this
requirement the health care facilities
which exclusively provide services on a
membership-based business model
or to persons who make a direct payment
without any reimbursement or third-party
payment
some folks have claimed that this is
going to actually help those with high
deductibles but it won't because the
only way to have the any payment
accredited to your high deductible
insurance plan is if you submit the bill
to the insurance company and that is
prohibited by the language of this
amendment
so it seems kind of like a minor change
right well it isn't
the comment that we're not seeing by
problem from something that doesn't yet
exist well golly
we wouldn't would we the question is
what will happen
such a change will allow a very small
number of for-profit Institutions
offering things like Urgent Care
birthing services or Ambulatory Surgery
to skim off the patients who can pay a
full cash price changing the payer mix
to the remaining hospitals or other
facilities
now maintaining pair mix is important
our critical access hospitals run on
razor thin margins
some of them actually just run a little
bit into the red they can't really make
it
and they lose money on services such as
full service 24-hour per day emergency
room and obstetrical services which
serve a lot of people on Medicaid or
with no insurance
again this is little Health you know
Health Care financing 101 here those
services
are which are critical to have in the
rural areas are subsidized by the higher
paying services and higher paying
insurances you go and you have your
total hip replacement done with
insurance that's going to be some of the
money that is going to help keep that
emergency room open so if you get run
over by a car you have a place to be
skimming off the higher paying patients
will have a significant negative
economic impact on our critical access
hospitals and we are seeing closures of
critical aspect access hospitals around
the country
there will be a substantial risk of
closure or the need to drop critical
service such as maternity and we've seen
that happen in this very state
because it is not a money-making
proposition
this will leave large number of
individuals especially in rural areas
like where I live with no access to
timely medical care for emergencies or
childbirth
the losses sustained by those facilities
will be shifted to those who have
insurance
driving up the cost for everyone else
and not changing that Total Health Care
cost
and a comment was just made about that
protection with a 15-mile radius
that's not sufficient to do anything I
live just a little over 15 miles from
either Huggins hospital or Memorial
Hospital
I have to drive over 15 miles for any
facility care for those who live in the
southern part of the state you're not
used to the kind of distances we have to
drive to get any kind of care
a facility placed for example in
Tamworth would not be governed by RSA
151 4A is it would be outside of that 15
mile radius and it could draw from both
so think about a woman in labor who
makes the mistake of going to a local
birthing center in her Town only
discover between contractions that they
only serve an elite group
she packs up drives perhaps another hour
to get to the only remaining hospital
that still offers maternity services
or she may deliver in her car in a
parking lot and we have certainly seen
that happen a great deal more after some
of our places have closed their
maternity Services we see an increased
number of babies who are delivered by
imtala emta la which is the emergency
medical treatment and Labor Act actually
prohibits turning her away this proposal
would violate emtala
now the sponsors presented this bill as
that's a rather unusual way to think of
the pre-mark free market because this
bill does not support a free market if
you give favorite treatment to
facilities using one business model at
the expense of others
as far as I know that's not the free
market
and the business model of our health
care System should not be to make money
off the Healthy and Wealthy
while letting the sick and less
this amendment will decrease access to
health care and will not drive down the
overall cost of Health Care
please press the red button to vote no
on this amendment and I do request
please a division vote
the motion before us is the Edwards
floor Amendment division has been
foreign
representative Osborne has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
place
representative
the motion before us is the Edwards
floor Amendment
this is a roll call vote
chair recognize the representative hunt
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know when I was sitting here
listening to a model that actually was
the original Managed Care model and it's
in California known as Kaiser perimente
maybe you've heard of it
Mr Speaker if I know that Kaiser
Permanente is a members only hospital
system
Mr Speaker wouldn't I love to have them
come to New Hampshire as another
competitive model for our health care
System
I think Mr Speaker I might want to press
chair recognize representative convert
Mr Speaker
if I know that our critical assets
access hospitals run on razor thin
margins and require a payer mix
which includes private pay in order to
maintain Revenue losing services such as
24-hour full-service emergency rooms and
obstetrical services
and if I know that I worked for a large
Managed Care Health Organization
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare back that's
not the insurance part but the provider
group and we took Medicaid
after a while we did in the beginning we
did later
and if I know that skimming off those
higher paying patients would have a
significant negative economic effect on
our critical access hospitals leading to
closures of obstetrical services and of
critical access hospitals which are
needed to provide timely care in our
rural areas
and if I know that the hospitals don't
want this the New Hampshire Hospital
Association testified against
hb1044 and lastly if I know that this
amendment will decrease access to health
care and will not drive down the cost of
Health Care would I then press the red
button to vote no to defeat this
the motion before us is the Edwards
floor Amendment it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
167 voting a
147-49 the Edwards floor amendment is
adopted motion before us now is auto
pass as amended on Senate Bill 430
. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
as opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
for what reason to memorize Mr Speaker
could I ask that the comments of this
previous debate be printed in the
permanent Journal
promise of the last debate
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill 438 FM
local
an act establishing State procurement
policies intended to promote the use of
American Materials having considered the
same we bought the same recommendation
that the bill ought to pass it's in a
Gerald Griffin for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same we report the same
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpeding to legislate
representative Leonard turcott for the
bills open bills open to Second reading
the further Amendment
representative turcott office floor
Amendment
chair recognized representative turkot
to speak to his Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
this is one for everybody
the house recently passed House Bill
1171 with a convincing bipartisan vote
of 201 to 147. we also passed HB 1560 on
a Voice vote
this floor amendment is a combination of
those two house bills the first part of
the cement streamlines the requirements
for individuals who hold and out of
current out of state barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics license by
requiring the New Hampshire Board of the
saying to recognize that out-of-state
license without any additional
repetitive and burdensome and
unnecessary requirements the second part
of the amendment would allow individuals
to provide blow-dry hair styling eyelash
extensions makeup application and
threading which is a type of hair
removal to clients by exempting these
four Niche Beauty services from
occupational and Shop license
licensure requirements these skills are
in fact first learned in the home in a
commonly practiced daily is routine
self-care
and beauty supplies for these skills are
ready readily available and accessible
and approached and are purchased by
average people of all ages every day
these skills are not even required to be
taught in cosmetology schools here in
New Hampshire so there is no reason we
should require a student to invest
substantial time energy and money
oftentimes incurring significant
financial debt please support this
amendment which will ease red tape and
unnecessary regulatory burdens by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is the turcotte
floor Amendment 1933h
are you ready for the question
division
representative Nunes requests the roll
calls that's sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
I'm just going to go right to The
Boatman
the motion before it's
is the Turk on floor Amendment 1933l
chair recognizes representative Osborne
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
language in this amendment has already
passed this house a few weeks ago and
that I believe that reducing the
burdensome uh
impediments to entry into the market of
Occupational licensing is a priority
the motion before us is the turkot floor
Amendment 1933l
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
[Music]
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
170 voting yay 129 voting Aid turcon
the motion before us now is ought to
pass as amended
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it and committed report
is adopted
the following reps declared conflicts of
interest on Senate Bill 438 it's in a
bruty d Silvestro
Egan Fenton massimilla shirtleff to
what reason to memorize to make a motion
[Music]
State your motion I'd like to pull
also be in order
[Music]
the mo the motion is to pull Senate Bill
Senator requests of roll calls that's
it's too late now got to stand up at
first
chair recognized
representative deshaies for a
parliamentary inquiry this is going to
be a division vote
if I know that the people of New
Hampshire deserve a debate on Senate
Bill 294 and the accompanying floor
amendments and Mr Speaker if I know that
a former Supreme Court Justice and the
committee chair prepared great speeches
to explain our bipartisan solution that
addresses all concerns raised by members
of this body and Mr Speaker I called
many of you and you agreed with the
compromise that we came up with in the
New Hampshire Chief police Chiefs
Association our constituents desire to
reform a currently broken bail reform
than when I press the green button to
pull Senate Bill 294 off of the table
thank you
chair recognize representative Byrd for
Mr Speaker if I know
the vote on the table in motion was
209-121
and Mr Speaker if I know why we voted
that way is because the house already
has a position on bail reform
and Mr Speaker I also know that there is
I understand there is five amendments to
this bill and at this time of day
I would press
the motion before us is to remove Senate
Bill 294 ref in from the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you
will press the green button of the
opposed or press the red button the
all members president our opportunity to
62 voting a 248-49 294 stays on the
table
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate bill 442fn and act
relative to the suspension of a vehicle
registration as a result of evading toll
collection systems consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
of Bill ought to pass
representative Leonard turcott for the
committee
Mr Speaker I've spoke against this bill
several of my friends are registering
their vehicles in Maine
I'm considering it
and there's eight total states that do
this
taking registrations away from people
for not paying their fines or paying
their tolls which in my eyes they should
be brought to court for not paying their
tolls just go to court and the Court's
going to say did you do it there's a
license plate there's a picture of it
yeah I did it all right then pay your
tolls and if you don't pay your tolls
you're going to be in trouble
you know this is a this is a court
matter it shouldn't be to pull your
registration because if you pull your
registration Mr Speaker then the person
can't get to work and pay his rent and
everything else or hers
because once we start this
we're going to add more things on it
next year
end the year after and the year after
and the year after because that's what
Connecticut did
they started with just pulling their
registrations on a few things now it's
virtually any tax that you do not pay
they pull your registration in
Connecticut and as I said last time Mr
Speaker if you uh the article that I
read in the paper
the Connecticut police said if you go
down any Street in Connecticut you'll
see at least one to three main license
plates
because that's what people are doing to
get away from this there is a loophole
that they're going to do because all you
have to do is register your car through
your LLC or a business in is a federal
matter at that point
so I hope you vote with me and say no to
this
and Mr Speaker
I have been here 12 years
and I have always known
foreign
good evening
sorry the finance has taken so much time
but anyhow
on um
this bill
registering your car in Maine
doesn't help you
because you will still have to pay the
fines
you will still have to pay the tolls
if you drive through them
without pain
this is
it has gone to the point
where
we have habitual offenders
you know kind of like alcohol
habitual offenders that just think that
it's okay
to not pay their tolls
you know forget the fact that you can
get one of those little
ID things for I think it's five dollars
and you can pay by your credit card
but they just refuse to do it and these
are people that use the toll roads every
single day
and they have thousands of dollars
that they owe to the state
and guess what
these are thousands of dollars that we
don't have to repair the turnpikes
you know it's just sitting out there
waiting for it to come in
so folks I ask you this is a
you know if you don't if you pay your
tolls you'll never have to worry about
this
if you don't pay your tolls shame on you
and you will have to worry about it so
please
please vote
green
the motion before us is ought to pass in
Senate Bill 442 are you ready for the
question
Senate bird has requested a roll calls
that's officially second it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
foreign
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate bill 442.
this is going to be a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if your opposer press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend to the state of
2001 voting yay 103 voting a committee
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate Bill 444 refn enact
relative to Childhood adverse
experiences treatment and prevention
have been considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that bill
ought to pass it's in a Mary Jane walner
for the committee
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 444 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
committee on finance to which those
referred Senate Bill 445 FN and act
relative to the Broadband matching Grant
initiative having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Gerald Griffin for the committee
the amendment is one five three seven
eight printed in house record 17 Page
96. you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye it
was supposed nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposing a
the eyes haven't committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred Senate Bill 458 FN
not relative there's a new new Youth
Services Center in operation of a
replacement secure facility consider the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Representative Keith Earth for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the falling
resolution solved that it's inexpedient
to legislate representative just Edwards
for the minority of the committee the
motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 458 FN are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the committee on finance the which was
referred Senate Bill 459 FN act relative
to Health Care Facility workplace
violence prevention program considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
to fill out a password Amendment
representative Sharon norgren for their
committee Amendment 1-871h printed in
house record 17 Page 97 through 101. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
there's a post nay
you always have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 459 FN are you ready for
some Sylvia requests the roll calls
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
amazing
pieces
the motion the motion before us
is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 459 FN this is a roll
call vote share recognizes
representative Sylvia for a
speaker Mr Speaker
if I know
that this bill is going to
accommodate businesses that are looking
for regulation and if I
believe that typically when businesses
are looking to be regulated they're
actually looking to prevent competition
from moving into the market
and if I believe those things then would
I press the red button
which I recognizes representative
Edwards for parliamentary inquiry uh Mr
Speaker first I want to thank
representative nordgren for letting me
do the pi on this
um Mr Speaker
um if if if I knew that
this bill
stripped out all of the punitive
portions of the bill
but left intact the part that the
hospitals and nurses wanted which was
the statistical Gathering and Reporting
and the periodic meeting if if I knew
those things remained as they requested
but with no penalty for anyone not
participating and if I knew that the
state-run hospitals were stripped from
this bill so there are no State costs
associated with this would I go ahead
and accept an extremely strong
bipartisan vote in the finance committee
and and push the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass
Senate bill 459. it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
foreign
oxenham
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
220 voting yay 87 voting a the committee
committee on Health and Human Services
in elderly Fiesta which was referred
enact establishing a supplemental
nutrition assistance program having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
Bill ought to pass with Amendment Museum
Nikki Kelsey for the committee amendment
is 1386h printed in House Records 17
Page 89. are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
aye
there's a post nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is ought to pass
with Amendment on Senate Bill 404 FN
this is a roll call vote Jr recognizes
representative Mark Pearson for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this is not
not a spending bill but a bill to get
the word out to Hungry people who do not
know what is available for them
and if I know that we've discovered for
every one dollar of federal money
brought into the state on such things we
get a dollar fifty in economic activity
would I not press the green button thank
the motion before us is not a pass that
Amendment on Senate Bill 404 FN this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press a green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
foreign
members president an opportunity to vote
226 voting yay 76 voting Aid a committee
report is adopted
chair recognize recognized as a member
from Charlestown
representative Stephen Smith for the
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session at the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only in resolutions by
caption only and that all bills are
ordered to third reading be read a third
time by this resolution and that all
titles of bills be the same as adopted
and that they'd be passed at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
it be to meet Thursday May 5th 2022 at 9
00 A.M
question is on the third reading motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Paul's nay the eyes have it and the
we have two unanimous consents
the chair recognizes representative true
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr today Mr Speaker today I will be
discussing the very well-known story of
David and Goliath
David the poor little Shepherd boy who
overcame All Odds and defeated the
impossible foe
I do give a hat tip and an
acknowledgment to author Malcolm
Gladwell
and his book David and Goliath underdogs
Misfits and the Art of battling Giants
so who was this Goliath
he was Goliath of gath
he was truly a giant among men
his height was six cubits in a span that
is over nine feet tall
Goliath was a warrior who wore a brass
helmet that weighed 30 pounds
he was protected by a brass a coat of
brass rings that weighed 125 pounds he
wore a brass armor to protect his legs
and brassama to protect his Shins
along with a sword and shield he carried
a spear that was 14 feet long
with a metal Point alone that weighed 15
pounds
all told the armor and weapons of
Goliath weighed over 700 pounds
so the story starts with the army of the
Philistines and the army of the
Israelites meeting in the valley of Eli
both armies took positions on opposite
Mountain sides because both of them were
smart enough to know you always want to
take The High Ground
neela Army would risk leaving The High
Ground to attack the other
so for weeks the mighty Goliath would go
down to the valley
every morning and every evening and he
would taunt the Israelites to send out
their Champion to decide the battle's
outcome in a single Mortal Combat
Goliath might have had one weakness he
might have suffered from acromegaly
that is a disorder that causes massive
bodily growth and can also bring about
very poor eyesight
the professional wrestler Andre the
Giant suffered from agromegaly
no Israelite would volunteer to fight
the Goliath in their right Minds no one
that is until David stepped forward and
who was David David was just a poor
little Shepherd boy now the job of a
Shepherd was to protect his flock
and they Protected Their flocks from
wolves
and they Protected Their flock from
wolves by using a sling
not a slingshot but a sling
it has been calculated that a rock slung
from a sling had the stopping power of a
45 caliber bullet
with their sling Shepherds could kill a
wolf from 50 yards
as a side note Julius Caesar's Legions
had battalions of slingers
who could bring Mayhem and death to
their enemies from over 100 yards away
and that reminds me virtual of the time
a couple of Roman soldiers very thirsty
looking for some beer walked into a bar
and said bartender five beers
but I digress
it is written that on that fateful day
Goliath was led down the mountain to the
valley floor
perhaps Goliath the giant had to be led
down the mountain because of his very
poor eyesight
David started down the mountain carrying
only his Shepherd's staff some locks in
his pouch and his slang
as David came down to the valley floor
Goliath seemed abubous to the fact that
David did not wear any armor
do not carry a sword did not carry a
shield
and Goliath said am I a dog that you
would come to me with sticks perhaps his
eyesight was so poor he confused the
shepherd's single staff with a bunch of
sticks
because of Goliath's poor eyesight he
couldn't see what David was Goliath said
come to me
come to me so that I may feed your flesh
to the birds of the heavens and the
Beast of the fields
Goliath was telling David to come close
I can't see where you are come close so
we can fight and I can kill you quickly
but David never had any intention of
getting anywhere near Goliath
from 10 to 20 yards away David wound up
his sling released the lock and hit the
giant smack in the forehead killing
Goliath
so perhaps the next time you hear the
story
about David
the poor little Shepherd boy
who overcame All Odds and defeated the
impossible foe perhaps you will think to
yourself
wait a minute
David wasn't the underdog
Goliath was the underdog
never even saw what hit him
Goliath never stood a chance
and now you know the rest of the story
recognizes representative soloway for
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you my colleagues for waiting
and for inviting me and my colleagues to
appear before you
I'm Jeffrey salloway I've served three
terms in the house I'm honored to be
permitted to speak and this is my last
hurray
you need no reminder that this house for
all its existence has been a first in
this nation
it has been first in defense of Freedom
you've heard that here today first in
defense of the nation first in its
commitment to the dignity
the
privilege the privacy and the respect
due to each and every one of its
citizens
other governments in this world have
been less noble
our house honors history it honors
memory
last week Jews Jews among you observed a
day of remembrance around the world Jews
and non-jews alike stopped for a long
moment to remember the multiple Millions
who perished in the Holocaust
in that horrible moment
Jews were executed
the Roma known commonly as gypsies were
executed
Evangelical Christians executed gay men
and women all executed
priests
lawyers
the developmentally challenged
the disabled anyone who was different
anyone who might speak truth to power
executed
one of the great Christian theologians
of the 20th century Dietrich Bonhoeffer
just before peace was declared
executed
many of those were the very kinds of
people who populate this house were it
today you my friends might very well
have been the victims
I speak in admiration today of our
honorable colleague the representative
from Acworth
who addressed this house two weeks ago
with wisdom and with passion she
reminded us of her own family's losses
to the Holocaust and of the value she
placed on the only Democratic state in
the Middle East and in response
so many of you Rose in acclamation
I must tell you you brought tears of
Pride to my eyes
I speak with praise for my colleague the
who co-sponsored HB 1135 mandating
Holocaust and genocide education in our
schools he stands with us today as I
express my personal gratitude to him and
his leadership
we have been a continuing voice for
human dignity this is the house in which
members support the Valiant struggle of
those in Ukraine who fight to preserve
freedom and human dignity this is the
house which next week will welcome Lech
Valencia a seminal architect of freedom
in Eastern Europe
yet it is not all congratulatory
we still find cobwebs in the corners of
our house
there are pockets of prejudice in our
state
yes even my friends in our own house
let us please guard our thoughts
dispel our biases reject our own
prejudices and the prejudices of others
to protect every New Hampshire citizen
regardless of religion regardless of
race regardless of gender regardless of
gender affiliation regardless of
ethnicity regardless of class because we
are the New Hampshire house we are
better than that may we continue to be
first in defense of Freedom First in
defense of our nation and first in a
commitment to the dignity and respect
that we provide each and every one of
our citizens I thank you for the
privilege of addressing you today thank
you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
foreign
being put in the personal Journal a
permanent Journal
chair
recognizes represent Auburn was in
Auburn moved at the house standing
research for the purpose of introduction
of bills and Road bills Amendment role
build reports and receiving messages are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye hello supposedly you guys
have it and the motion is adopted the
house is in recess until tomorrow